Oh you dirty freaks.
It is
Monday April 22nd.
Two days after 420 and I'm here
with my man Tony Hinchcliffe.
He has never been an individual guest on
the podcast for but we've done podcast
before under the Icehouse Chronicles
which by the way is available on the desk
one label on iTunes as
well as the whole areas.
KEVIN PEREIRA As podcast called pointless
muff said if you want to hear chicks
talk about sucking decks and stuff.
Oh that's video games and comic books.
Well how about we just give
him a little false advertising.
Brian maybe.
Maybe you get more people don't you
know what this country runs on son.
No I'm upset with what's right.
Ryan killed Ryan Kelly.
Very very funny and talented Ryan Keeling
and Brian also does a gang of shows
and he's doing some soon in San Francisco
and Sacramento at the punch line in
Sacramento.
And with this man Tony Hinchcliffe
you'll be there as well.
And what were we doing the apples here.
Yeah I was talking about this.
Tony.
Tony it's because finance.
I was Tony road.
It's great.
He cries when you fuck him.
But.
Here here here here.
But tell that to legendary comedy clubs
Sam Tripoli as well our boy Sam Tripoli
who's one of my very good friends
in comedy for many many years.
He's a fucking beautiful human being I
love that guy and very funny as well.
And so they are at Cobb's on Sunday May
5th and May 3rd and 4th they're at the
punch line in Sacramento.
And if you've never been to the punch
line in Sacramento I've never been to a
comedy club.
The punch line in Sacramento is like
one of the perfect comedy clubs to go to
because it's been around for ever.
This as well as places like I don't
remember the first time I worked there.
But it was well over a decade ago it's a
bad ass old school comedy club and some
great great great comedy has been done
on that stage perfectly set out really
intimate seating.
So it's a bad ass place to
see three very funny guy.
So May 3rd and 4th at the punch line in
Sacramento and May 5th at Cobb's and in
San Francisco and there
might be a surprise guest
there might not be though too
there might not be may be AIDS get
stronger maybe World War Z is for real but
maybe there's gonna be a big guest maybe
there's a lot a lot of times you can't
say because the reason being I'd say if
you're doing a show like this like we
might have a friend that's in town it
says hey I want to do the show but they
don't want to advertise because they
have a committed gig within X amount of
miles with an X amount of months and
sometimes not supposed to say that you're
doing a gig like that's why.
Like if you go to like some some guys you
don't have a hard time with the Comedy
Store for putting your name up there
because they would have like a gig they
were doing in a big place
or try to sell tickets for.
So we'd have an arrangement.
So that's why I can't say but
it might be someone very funny.
It might be somebody that
hardly ever leaves L.A.
and hardly ever leaves the Comedy Store.
Mm hmm.
Wow this is exciting.
I want to know who it is.
Okay.
I don't even know who the fuck it is yet.
I think I do.
If if it is I think it is he's awesome.
Yeah they're the comedy stores
that means 80 percent awesome.
You know even the 20 percent mediocre
it's probably better than what you got in
your town anyway.
Yeah.
So you're a powerful Ryan Keeley
mob said All right you guys.
We.
This podcast is brought to you by Tang.
I'm so glad that when when we we pick up
a podcast sponsor you're always like oh
what if these kinds of douche bags you
know like what if that's like a big fear
you know when you take on
a sponsor because you know
I'm on network I don't have
a channel I'm just you know I'm just
doing this thing and I'm trying to like
navigate all this stuff by myself.
So
my attitude with the whole thing was
I looked and I said the most important
thing first of all is that I don't feel
duty like whatever we're selling and
everybody's like then it's too
late for you know for brain do she.
You know I just want to make sure that
what we're selling is a good product.
So I get all these emails and tweets
tweets especially sometimes about talking
about people saying how much money they're
saving on Tang and guy one guy talked
about it a couple of weeks ago.
He wrote to me.
He chopped his bill down
from 90 bucks to like 18.
I don't know how the fuck he
did I know what he's doing.
That sound sounded completely outrageous.
Well my bill has been that guy
about twenty five dollars a month.
I mean and I have to say that this is
my second phone and this is you know my
massage parlor phone.
Dan would you say that you use it 50
percent as much as you earlier your other
phone or I'd probably say my other phone
I use it 50 percent more maybe it's
maybe a little bit a little
bit higher maybe 60 maybe six.
So probably be the equivalent of sixty
dollars someone like that would you say
that.
Yeah that makes sense.
Yeah.
So if that's still him it's still
cheaper than then what like.
Right now I have you know the iPhone
through AT&T as my main phone and that's
about one hundred and twenty
two hundred ten dollars a month.
You
know it's fucking very pricey.
Yeah.
What thing does is they first of all they
use the Sprint network then have their
own network these one of the major
networks in this country one that you know
it's it's got 4G it's it's excellent and
they also have the highest level of the
most technologically advanced Android
phones all these new fucking killer
Android phones like the Samsung Galaxy
S3 and the Samsung Galaxy Note They have
the note 2 as well they're fucking
incredibly things he used to be like you
really lost something if you didn't get
an iPhone like you really have you try
to have one of those early
Android they were dog shit.
I had the first one was Oh you're so
stupid those things are horrible that and
those BlackBerry touch screens these
to have eyes to have one of those the
BlackBerry Storm.
Yeah fuckin storm of shit.
So that was diarrhea and that's stupid
shit bag phone but these SAMs I have the
Galaxy S3 it's fucking awesome it's great
it's the coolest thing ever for like
looking at websites.
It's huge and it's very fast as well like
the processor and it's not like clunky
like like the droids of all.
So anyway the waiting has it set up
is they have no contracts so you buy a
device set it up and go.
You can go fuck yourself you could just
cancel not only that they credit you on
unused service if you if you use only
a certain amount of your bill they
actually like knock you down to the
next level and your next bill and they
credit you the difference
it's it's beautiful it's
everything you could ask for
from a big company like a company that's
dead I mean they're not one of the
bigger cell phone companies.
I mean how many cell phone companies
are there actually really stop thinking
well there's like the big five or whenever
you like T-Mobile Ryan Verizon AT&T
it's like you generally thought of it's
like this it's like a rise in powerful
AT&T powerful T-Mobile
you're on a budget yeah yeah.
Right now it is it's crazy
because T-Mobile as you
know they're new towers are
pretty advanced and they don't have that
fucking you know bandwidth hogs that
you know AT&T and Verizon they're their
bandwidth I mean so many people are on
their network when something goes down
half the people have Verizon or AT&T you
know they're not gonna have cell phone
service but then you have like T-Mobile
guys they're like No I'm fine.
That's a very good point.
Yeah.
And Sprint is a big one.
Joey Diaz That's him forever.
He loved it.
I've never had it other than this
but I've got no problems with it.
Yeah and the though the whole idea behind
thing is that they're just going to
offer you a service that's you
know it's just it's reasonable.
You don't have to get fucked over it
doesn't have to be this idea that we all
think that every company should try to
squeeze every last dollar out of every
last customer.
I think that shit's stupid.
I think most people rise
up realizing that as well.
So go to Rogan distinction and you can
save yourself twenty five dollars off of
either a phone or service from a very
cool company were also brought to you by
square space.
So you have to ask yourself do
you want to make a web site.
Bitch that's my question to you bitch.
Do you want make a web site.
And if you do let's get a real
young guy learn no HMO OK.
You're not going to use it.
It's just not gonna happen.
Okay let's be honest.
Another thing
you don't need to begin to you to really
learn how to put all that shit in and
it's gonna be all fucked up and then
you gonna try to what look at it unlike
Windows Internet Explorer.
It's going to shit.
But look it works on safari.
You don't have to do that anymore.
What square space you can go there
and you can create your own Web site.
It's so easy that you can setup a store
just like that Bryant did it while we
were doing the commercial Bryant
registered a fucking thing on square space
started.
What was it called.
And it was all on the servers.
Now that was a different looks.
However you did for square space 2.
No I made a web site but if you're
thinking of I bought Digg party.
Oh you'd buy Digg party my mouth dot com
dot com although and then didn't you.
But didn't you build a
website with square space.
Yeah.
I did a dolphin.
Sex dolphin website.
I tried to do it right now.
It's Brian.
Look Brian is much more technically
advanced than or aware than I'll ever be.
He can throw one of these fucking things
together very quickly and he did it
through square space.
You know why we're just all
still doing a show as well.
It's super easy if you go to square
space dot com forward slash job.
You can sign up with no credit
card needed and just try it out.
You just start building a website and
if you decide to purchase use the offer
code Joe 4 and Joe and 4 for April.
That's all one word or one thing.
Joe for.
And then you get 10 percent off your
first purchase on new accounts includes
monthly and annual plans.
And again that square space
dot com forward slash Joe.
And if you're going to enter in the code
use the code Joe for CSL some shekels
sun on your fat juicy Web site.
It's
definitely I can create
a Web site on this.
In a way that I never could in real life
because I am just way too HDD for that
shit.
I'm not going to learn and do that.
I had to.
I have one where I'm trying to keep
up with but this looks this looks even
better.
It's dope pretty easy.
Super easy.
Yeah yeah it's good.
Go get it.
So delicious.
We're also brought to
you by Audible dot com.
I was actually listening to.
Do you know why I got hooked on man.
I'm hooked on now.
How dare you.
I read super awesome Dan
Carlin's Hardcore History.
Oh yeah.
Dude.
God damn.
Ever since we had a guy on
the show we had on a podcast.
Guy was great to talk to.
Fascinating guy.
Really really interesting intelligent guy
but when it comes to history he's been
putting together like forever.
He's been putting together these history
podcasts and they're like a show.
It's not like a podcast like this sloppy
unorganized mass that I try to fucking
serve up to Fox.
Dan Carlin puts on a god damn show and
he he puts it on in like this really
entertaining way and gives you this
thorough history of all these events but
like really exciting stuff.
What are you doing.
You chatting with Kara.
I care.
I'm single you.
Hey dude how dare you.
How dare you even give
people the idea to do that.
No care is gonna be super upset
with you and probably sue this show.
Fine.
I'll see what I'm here is like some
super hardcore feminist and she's like
enough Joe Rogan.
What if she's in India fingering yourself.
Oh easy over here with the thing
is I'm on hardcore history.
I'm on the.
The Mongols.
Now he's got this.
I don't know how many parts it is.
I mean part 3.
It's fucking amazing.
It's so great and it's
available on audible dot com.
He's got all the back episodes.
I mean he's been doing it
since I think he said 2005.
So you know this guy's got a solid
eight years of podcasts under him.
It's crazy and they're awesome.
I listened to one on Germany in
World War 2 the bombings of Europe.
He's so fucking cool to listen to.
It's really bad ass if you go to all
we've got Audible dot com Ford slash Joe.
You can try audible free for 30 days
and get a free audio book not just that
they also have standup comedy on there
they have a huge selection of audio
entertainment not just books but podcasts
like Hardcore History and and so many
other really interesting things to
listen to including our pals Opie and
Anthony.
You can you can get
that on audible as well.
It's a cool service and
I've been a fan for years.
I'm a huge fan of audio
books this Hardcore History
has been making my life like
so much more interesting
the last couple of days.
Like when I get in my car I'm not like
thinking oh you know you get my car and
drove and probably stuck in traffic I'm
going to go all let's hear more about
the Mongols.
That's what I'm thinking.
It's just Genghis Khan
was a mother fucker.
Yeah dude King Kong killed almost
70 million people by some counts.
Some accounts say more than that.
Some accounts say but
as little as 10 million.
Like He definitely killed 10 million.
God damn it's unbelievable.
That's the best.
They're talking about armies that were
coming towards China where the Mongols
had been and in the distance they
thought they saw snow covered mountains.
But when they got close they
realized there were mounds of bones.
Oh my God.
The Mongols had killed 10 million people
in this one town they came to this
gigantic state and just
killed 10 million people.
It was amazing.
I mean horrific terrifying.
Just the idea that that at one point
in time just in the twelve hundred's
relatively short amount of time ago there
was a guy who brought a bunch of other
dudes with him on horseback and just
fucked up the whole world banded together
took hostages took the hostages pushed
them to the front lines so the hostages
would literally lead the way and people
would be defending their towns having to
shoot arrows at their own friends who
had been kidnapped their own loved ones
their own children the Mongols
were fucking terrifying.
It's terrifying to think that just a
thousand years ago not even there was a
dude who figured out a way to get
hundreds of thousands of mass murderers to
work together.
Hundreds of thousands of serial killers.
Hundreds of thousands of brutal rapists.
Hundreds of thousands of
ruthless remorseless murderers.
And they got together on horseback.
It takes one convincing leader.
God damn Genghis Khan must have been a
mother fucker because there was nobody
like that before and nobody liked that
since his sons tried to hang on to it for
a little while but you know what.
The reign of power all really came
through that one bad motherfucker.
They had a crazy saying that an armies
of donkey led by a lion could conquer an
army of lions led by a donkey.
They were all about tactics and they
would beat much larger armies with severe
superior strategy and cunning
and just ruthlessness.
Just everybody was terrified of them.
They just they killed everybody man men
women children babies they didn't give a
fuck.
They killed everybody.
They eight people.
They hate each other.
They got too hungry.
They would draw straws maybe or figure
out how they would figure out you know if
someone's gonna sacrifice themselves so
that the army could go on and they would
slaughter them and eat them and cook them.
Dude it's unbelievable.
I was only a thousand years ago.
What the fuck man.
You think it will ever anybody
else ever pull that off again.
That kind of craziness
that's terrifying to wonder.
I think if you had to worry about
anything it would be worry about all this
beautiful city shit shutting down.
That's the real fear.
The real fear is we have some massive
disaster like a solar flare that knocks
out our power grid and our
ability to pump gas is gone.
Our ability to drive back
and forth to places is gone.
Our ability to get food people's gone
and then you realize how nutty we are
spread out and how dangerous this is and
how vulnerable we are living like this.
I think you would take something like
that to bring people to some place where
you could get that many
psychopaths all together again.
Yeah I think now that we have the
internet if the Internet went down I think
shit we get crazy really quick because
everybody needs it and is used to it now.
Everything down to the G.P.S.
and just everything.
Yeah we're terrified.
I'm terrified of leaving leaving the
house that my fucking cell phone right.
I'm a little bitch.
I'm a little bitch the machine.
Speaking of machine we're
talking about the human machine.
Our last sponsor on it dot com.
We sell all kinds of cool
shit to get your Fitness on.
We've got kettle bells battle robes.
The newest edition weight vests.
No that's not armor Bryan.
It's a weight vest.
It's not armor even though it
pride protect you a little bit.
There we go.
We also have steel Masons and steel clubs.
These are not weapons.
These are designed for
functional athletic improvement.
What all these things that were selling
like kettle bells and battle ropes.
They're all for what's to develop
what's best to develop what they call
functional strength.
We have medicine balls as
well functional strength.
We sell a pull up bar functional strength
like the ability to move your body
around as one unit.
It's one of the most important aspects
of fitness and one of the things that
people screw up on is if
they try to get in shape.
They don't know what the fuck they're
doing they do like too many bicep curls or
too many like bench presses and shit
you can whack your body out making it
imbalanced.
It's one of the best ways to get fit
like a full body fit is to do things that
require you to use the body as one unit.
I'm obsessed with that.
Obviously that's why I talk about
it every week but I've seen massive
improvements for my jujitsu
athletic benefits of training
like this and I always
encourage people to do it
because really fun too.
And you can get a great workout and
literally in 20 minutes you could do a
brutal Kettlebell workout in 20 minutes.
Follow a DVD that Keith Webber DVD that
we have the extreme kettlebell DVD is
fucking awesome and follow 20 minutes of
it you'll get crushed and you'll you'll
feel good you feel fantastic
so go there good on it.
Comments.
I win in 90 lots of different supplements
we have now vitamin C and l lysine and
we sell melatonin spirulina Arctic cod
liver oil we're trying to sell you just
the best shit for your health and for
fitness and things along those lines and
if you use the codename Brogan You
will save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
How long.
How long till you have
like a health helmet.
If we if it comes out do we'll sell it.
If there's a health element that comes
out that puts you in a healthy state of
mind.
What if there was a helmet that came on
that immediately felt like someone was
sucking your dick.
How.
How quick before they
would make that illegal.
Like immediately like they found a spot
on your brain where they can joke with
electricity and it totally feels like
someone's sucking your dick a helmet that
helps your helmet a
helmet for your helmet.
Exactly how much do you think they
would make that women would make that
illegal.
Would it be men and maybe a little bitch
about it a lot of men would make it
illegal because they'd never get
real blow jobs over again girls.
But just put the fucking helmet on
kind of why do you want me to do this.
It'd be a tough situation for women if
the helmet worked that well it came.
You think they would lose a
little bit of their value.
Is that what you're saying.
Oh yeah I think I should be walking
her out these helmets on helmet.
What's the normal thing.
How much time do you think it is
before something like that is invented
something that can recreate an artificial
experience like almost almost exactly.
I'll bet you 15 20 years.
I bet it's not that far away.
The way things are moving and shaking
there's probably a bigger team of
scientists on that right now
than there is on cancer research.
You're right.
Everybody is building the helmet.
Everybody wants to get their
dicks sucked and then wrote on it.
Thought Tom Ford slashed Joe.
Cue the music Brian.
Let's get this bitch started.
Boom son
the will gain experience.
We're full Tony.
George Clooney.
That's me.
That's the song.
That's the powerful Tony Hinchcliffe song.
I say it like that.
I sing like a woman.
And then you go.
That's me like a little kid.
Hey everybody.
Somebody put that on a loop
when you have your own podcast.
What are you guys going to do a podcast
that once you guys where it are in the
works it starts Oh okay Lucky.
Two weeks.
I think we sat in preproduction.
Yeah niceness niceness until he's gonna
be with me on this Wednesday night at
the icehouse went to the ice ones it.
Sure.
10:00.
OK.
Brian's going to be there too as
well as Tom Seger and Burt Krisha.
Oh shit bitches.
That's right.
You heard sweet.
Tony is an up and coming young standup.
I love one of my favorite
things in life for real.
This really is absolutely true is when
I don't know about someone and then I
find out that they're funny.
Like when I found out about it from Brian.
Brian told me about you.
And as a comedian like one of things that
every comedian always loves is seeing
a new comedian like some.
Someone who knew who's funny like does
another one say oh there's another one
you know and different
styles and different you
know different takes but when
they're funny like it's really
it gives you a lot of hope.
And I was I was in L.A.
the entire time like you started comedy
and you know and then started getting a
little a name for yourself.
And then eventually got to the point
where you're you know regularly doing you
know podcasts and comedy clubs and yeah.
So that's that's a
really cool thing to say.
Yeah it's really so much fun.
Pretty incredible.
So few people pull it off.
You know I love watching somebody who
comes through like some new person is
funny.
It's like because we to all the class
thing and like you said everybody's a
little bit different.
Everybody has their you
know their take on things.
But when you find one there's nothing
cooler it's sort of like when you love
comedy it's like watching a baby
being born like just like that.
Wow.
Yeah.
Larson's hilarious and when.
You know like you when you run into
someone and you you realize that you know
they started out sucky and you probably
saw them in like those during those
first couple of months.
And then within a couple of years they
become competent and then boom they
become really good and they like
like Ari is my favorite example.
Oh yeah.
I was there when Ari first got on stage
like one of his first sets one of the
earliest sets.
And you know I've watched him become like
a real killer like Ari Shapiro is like
a real killer.
He did.
Tom Seger is party of day top scorer
had a benefit rather for his doggy.
He got a sick dog.
If you if you love dogs
you love Tom Segura.
I don't know how you would donate.
I think they have like a paper out there
so don't go to your mom's house podcast
on your mom's house podcast dot com.
Tom Sawyer is just one
of the coolest guys ever.
And he had the show and Ari went up and
fucking destroyed destroyed with a bunch
of shit that I hadn't heard before to
those couple bits that were really funny
that were new.
He writes like a machine.
Yeah he's awesome.
He's isn't here.
He's just coming up with so much content.
Yeah.
I think he also realizes at this time
that he's like you know he's again he's
like a real comic now.
Now it's just a matter of doing the work.
And he's a smart dude you know he knows
how to he knows how to put it down.
He knows what needs to be done and he
can go get it done just as as a fan of
comics.
It's so cool and someone pops up.
There's another one I got really lucky
with Ari because he was the first person
I asked me to do a gig
with him and Sam Tripoli.
So was those two guys all of a sudden
all at once I went to La Hoya with Sam
first and then did a gig
and like Irvine with Ari.
What year was this.
This is about 2008.
That's so recently.
That's awesome.
Five years I don't think of it as being
recently but you know there was like a
year or so that I was doing it before
you even get a road gig like that you're
just building it.
I was you know just riding my
bicycle from open mike to open mike.
How many guys that started out with you.
You know we all have like kind of like
groups of people that we sort of start
off around a similar time and then you
watch each other either fall off or give
up or are some people get through the net.
How many people that with your class
do you think got through with my true
class.
I'd probably say about good.
It's a tough one because
we're still pulling you know
and I mean you still don't
know who can make like a bit throw a
right hook right at the end before they
drop out and have a new 15 minutes
the crushes and it's a breakthrough.
But I probably guess about
seven or ten right around there.
That's a good number.
Like still doing I mean you know I'm
counting my original starting classes like
a good you know 60 70 80 90 right people
because I know the I mean I stayed in
Hollywood and built in Hollywood like
Los Angeles because I feel like a lot of
people start somewhere
and then come to L.A.
I'm like You know what I'm going to.
I wanted to just have a like an NBA style
perspective like Chappelle once said
and he was doing a spot on stage one
night and the LR really late crushing
making it look like I mean
it was just unbelievable.
And the three or four hours and he goes
the back Laramie goes hey how many guys
are L.A.
comics and a lot of people clapping.
But how many of you are like work here
at the Comedy Store and started here at
the Comedy Store.
That was just two or
three of us that clap.
He goes You guys are insane.
He's performing to a
lot of comedians right.
So the thing with him coming back a few
years ago was like the audience that got
to be there was there but the back
of the room filled up to the gills.
Right.
And he said that it's like learning how
to dribble in the NBA starting comedy at
the Comedy Store.
And it's so true.
But but if you think about that start
learning how to dribble in the NBA and
you're you and you're just used to the
motion of a thousand miles an hour.
Yeah then that works out.
I think it's like anything else.
You know it's a more difficult but
also more rewarding pursuit pursuit.
You know you can take an
easy route through life or
you can you know I mean it's
not as hard as being a Navy SEAL.
Let's be honest you know even though
doing comedy is hard and a lot of people
don't ever figured out it's not nearly
as hard as doing something you hate and
being stuck working 40 hours a week at
this job for the rest of your life until
your heart stops beating because
you have no passion right.
And I mean it was a real struggle for a
few years I really threw myself to the
wolves.
I didn't have sure I
didn't have money saved up.
I was just I was just doing it and then
I got the job working at the Comedy
Store a couple of months
and like as a door guy.
So I started getting spots a lot
there which is what I wanted.
You know the problem the story
like yours is that it worked.
So there's a lot of the dudes out
there that will try that same thing but
they're not fucking funny at all.
You know what's tough is it is I noticed
that a lot a lot of people come up to
me and say I'm thinking
about starting standup Tony.
You know what do you what do you think
and sometimes they don't they just
sometimes I wonder out of all the times
I get asked this from somebody that
wants to start standup it's like you have
to really have a crazy mind ingrained
in you it's not something
you start and learn like.
I was in trouble.
Every class in school not once a day at
school like every class every teacher
hated me.
I never touched and I was never like
spilled milk on somebody I never did
anything physical but verbally I was just.
It's the it's what I did is pretty crazy.
And I mean you know like so you just
always talk to Russia totally to the
extreme all the time.
And that's that's like Kid energy you
know I'm talking about the fun even now.
Now I'm like I'll even.
I'm still young it's like I'm not half
of the quick wit that I used to be before
I realized I wasn't now I overthinking
is a defense thing you learned it from
your parents like I learned of you Dad.
It's really an interesting situation is
the way I raised I was raised with so
weird that I know it has something to
do with that because I have these four
older brothers and sisters
that are much older than me.
So it's like I mean it's 12 years between
me and my closest sibling and they're
all much older.
Oh wow yeah.
So you probably exposed to like they
probably give you a hard time and pretty
fucked with you really they
were absolutely all super cool.
They were actually super cool.
That's how I and that's sometimes I
wonder how it didn't end up like that.
I mean there were times you know there
was the old you know you were adopted.
Why do you think you're.
Well you know what.
When they're 12 years apart I don't
think you're actually going to get them
because they're gonna be sweet to you
you're like happy for a little brother and
sister.
It's when you two years apart you know.
Yeah I've I've known a lot of brothers
beat the fuck out of each other.
Yeah.
Obviously that album Luckily with the
age gap like they were in college when I
was you know in kindergarten and stuff.
What was interesting about
that is I definitely think
it played a role because I
was hanging out with 20 year olds when
I was a little kid and they probably
thought I was really funny
when you talk shit too.
Totally.
This whole thing.
That's what I would do I would talk shit
and I would put on terrible magic shows
in which the whole ongoing joke was that
you can clearly see you know I had not
seen comedian magicians right yet.
I was just trying to do magic but I was
bad at it but I could just the way I
like that and well it started I had to
get good at doing it on purpose because
it was happening accidentally and I
would just try to follow through with it.
So you started off trying to be good.
Yeah
right.
But then I just got good
at being that magic.
Yeah it's a funny thing when you see
someone who grew up like in a weird spot
like that.
I think all of us like every comic I
know grew up in some sort of a weird
situation where some basic
need wasn't fulfilled.
So that creates like
this weird personality.
Totally.
I even though I love comics when that
when it doesn't create that weird
personality it just creates fucked up
people you know like if you don't put it
to use like creating something that weird
energy that comes out of a weird life.
If you did that shit will haunt you like
that can that can wreck your life if
you're one of those really creative people
or more impulsive people and doesn't
do anything about it don't doesn't
focus in on something yeah.
And it's just that's an interesting
point because with me I didn't have any
creative outlet until like after high
school because the theater woman always
wanted me to join theater.
Yeah but I never did.
And I mean the only outlet other than
doing it in front of people all the time
and just you know being me I had nothing.
So then I spent a few
years like what am I.
Because you don't know
if you're just a kid that loves making
people laugh that you can be a standup
comedian right.
When you're in Ohio
there's no people in L.A.
are really lucky or in New York around
those areas because there's comedy there
at least you can stumble across a comedy
club and go and wonder what's going on
there.
I might go in there tonight just one time.
First time I was ever at a comedy club
was at the Comedy Store and I had signed
up for the open mike and gotten on.
So it's very grandiose.
I mean you know it's like my
heart was beating out of my chest.
I knew that it was something I was gonna
be doing forever no matter what how you
knew it.
You know it was something I definitely
didn't know the first time I went on
stage
I was I was scared shitless to the waist.
More scared than I
thought I was going to be.
Oh I never I It is unbelievable.
It is so creepy because what ended up
happening was is I've blanked out and
forgot everything that I'd been and
that was the one time that I was I had a
couple months to prepare
for three minutes.
Did you bring notes on stage with you.
No I never liked.
I've never liked having
notes onstage with me.
That was a big thing man
getting rid of your notes.
I was a big thing back in the day.
Going on stage with notes still.
Yeah.
Because in the beginning I definitely
went on stage with notes when I first
started doing it but I saw like really
good guys go on stage with notes when
they were working on new shit.
Yeah it became like part of the act
that they let you know they were trying
stuff out by looking down at the paper.
But you try to do the first one free ball.
Yeah like really bad in a I somehow was
just digging myself out by calling out
how terrible it was.
I just I was basically saying
Wow I just blanked out.
And I've been getting ready for this
for so long and so I just ended up doing
what actually ended up sort of becoming
my style which is like calling out
whatever's happening in the room except
I was just joking about me bombing.
You kind of have to call out
what's happened in the room right.
Oh yeah.
And that's that's one.
Another good thing rather that the
comedy store provides no crowd control.
Right.
None.
That place is madness.
There's something I could be madness.
That's why I like it was so modern.
Anything can happen at the Comedy Store.
So like for example like when we did
that show in Indianapolis and I came out
and I'm looking at the masses of people
but the first thing that I notice to my
left is this lady lit up next to the
stage that's doing sign language to the to
the audience.
And I just couldn't help but the start
like I always say you know it started
just with I've never performed in
front of one of these people before.
I've always wondered
what that would be like.
And I'm noticing that she has to keep
up with everything that I'm saying.
So like I went off on this whole run
about it that it's just so much fun for me
and I could trust my instinct and just
keep going with it because I even though
like I wouldn't have known to do that
if I was just trying to just put on like
an act.
Right.
Yeah.
Which is also great.
But I got to go off on a run there and
I could trust that instinct you know by
the end I have her doing blow job motions
to her face because I realized that if
I said the word blow job she has to do
that jerk off that is on her face or off
on the face is the that's
the sign language for that.
Yeah.
This is blow job or at least
that's what she was doing.
Actually was he because they switched
halfway through the whole thing but they
switched the trick was like enough tone
handling so I think so I just quit.
I don't I don't know what happened how
did you have a backup so close that you
they get tired I guess so signing maybe
you need like really good hand cardio
but not being crazy.
I had you know crazy a ton of tweets.
Indianapolis was so much fun and everybody
was like hash tagging sign language
because I couldn't even
believe what was going on.
Yeah I did that once in San Francisco
a guy brought his own remember that.
Yeah.
And he sat right in the front.
Guy brought his own sign person.
I was like wow that's pretty gangster.
Guy was deaf.
You want to go see some comedies like
I'm tell you they're saying Yeah you look
really nice guys.
That was a fun show.
He did.
I forget what he did because it was a
I was obviously timing things he didn't
talk.
It was really funny.
It was really funny like you could tell
the guy like really enjoyed standup
comedy.
And even though he was
deaf he still understood.
Like what.
You know he understood jokes.
It's got to be weird because he's
only getting it like two dimensional.
Right.
You don't if you don't hear it.
Yeah man you're missing so much.
Like there's a lot of guys like Joey Díaz
perfect example of you half of what's
funny is how he sounds like you know the
way sounds is the fucking intensity of
his voice.
Well it's like when he when he hits
those six when he starts screaming about
something like he was screaming about
it's blue cheese with buffalo wings or go
fuck your mother it was
just fucking ranch dressing.
He went on his rant about ranch dressing
and on paper it's like there's nothing
funny about that at all.
But if you hear him if you
hear Joe and you see him do it.
It was one of the finest fucking things
I've seen with other passion the arms
from deep but I mean maybe this guy had
like a deep sense of his own timing.
You know he can interpret it in the finest
way because he was obviously a fan of
stand up comedy enough to hire
his own sign language person.
Yeah I've been at a college show once
were they they made them have a sign
language it was like a part of the rules.
Like if someone spoke they
had to have someone there.
That's a I was wondered how
complicated is that sign language.
I mean it seems like it seemed really I
was watching some parts of it because at
one point when you were on I walked
around and sort of was watching from the
side ledge area and I noticed that when
you said the word at one point polite
cock this guy had to do this thing
where it was this giant like right.
Well that's the strap on bit.
Right.
Well it was it was something.
It was when you were taking questions
at the end it was like you were talking
about Dennis Rodman's cock
or something like that.
He was like oh very improvised.
Oh the Kim Jong Il thing I was noticing
this guy has to do this thing like that
black cock and sign language.
Is this.
It's like so stereotypical like it's just
giant and his hands were so far apart
it is like he was describing a
tree stump or something like that.
Like this hand climbing.
I'm like that's black
cock and sign language.
Isn't that hilarious.
That's what they would come up with.
That's the move.
Yeah.
So blow job is this.
I don't know why it's down.
Why does it go down.
It seems that you're always on your knees.
But that's an awkward angle
tells us to do your blog.
That is why it would
be I see a blond giant.
Like a child made sign me.
You know if so get on a chair.
That's ridiculous angle to have that
standard angle to suck a dick and doesn't
make any sense at all.
I'm not going to fire it.
You almost killed.
So the first time may say laugh just
thinks it was brilliant at the time was
absolutely brilliant.
It was the perfect time if
at first you don't succeed.
Phi Phi again.
To you guys get a room get a room.
Yeah.
Fuck
yeah.
We're gonna have to share a room
when we're in the same Sacramento.
I'm sharing a room.
And so why you sharing rooms.
Because listen getting your
own rooms you fucking weirdo.
Grown men stop pretending
like you're in high school.
OK we're going to get up to her
door we're gonna go fishing.
Get a hotel room together.
Shut the fuck up to get your own room.
God damn it was thirty dollars and
ninety cheap fuck thirty dollars a night.
Well have you seen the commercials.
We'll keep the light on for you.
Thirty dollars and thirty bucks.
Joe we were talking about
it on a recent podcast.
I think you're there Tony.
I think it was Ari was saying it was he
was talking about how funny it was going
to the grocery store with you because
like you'd be like you know how much is
macaroni or pasta sauce like you
know 20 dollars whatever it was.
What is toothpaste.
Two dollars.
I don't know what I think.
I haven't forever.
Eddie Bravo always makes fun of it says
that I would be the worst person ever on
the price is right now because I
literally don't know anything costs.
So far there's only room enough my
fucking hand for so much show against it.
There's no room for that.
I just got no room for as long as people
aren't riding the streets over the
price of toothpaste.
If they are then I'll
start paying attention.
It's like I've got shit to do.
I can't be worrying about what shit
costs as long as it's fairly reasonable.
But I have friends that are like wealthy
and you hear them go a steak for thirty
nine dollars.
Are you telling me that the
state cost thirty nine dollars.
Why is this steak three.
Hey just what are you What are you doing.
What do you do it's a number.
So what does it even mean.
What the fuck is it even based on.
Just shut your mouth.
You're not broke.
Spend the thirty nine bucks you cheap
fuck you whining asshole you yammering
fucking perspective lapping douche bag.
You know we'll get it together you fuck.
I went something a real person.
Oh what's that Morton's
Steakhouse is a wonderful place.
Yeah I love it and I was just in that
it was the only place near me that had
crab legs and it cause I was just since
Vegas I've been thinking about those
crab legs from Vegas and I'm 9 yeah from
9 which is most amazing place ever so I
went there to get on and a half pound
was sixty like sixty five dollars and I
was like That's a lot.
You get a lot.
Four legs is what it was.
But did you watch that
show with the dudes die.
Get on those fucking crab boats.
No I didn't.
That's that's why it's so much it's
because it's really hard to get.
That's what world Deadliest Catch with.
This is what I was getting at.
Then the two days later I was thinking
like that didn't I want wanted more.
Know I wanted to eat right.
Right.
You know what I mean.
So then I went to Olive
Garden and they had a weight.
So I went to the place next door and
stay which is like Outback Steakhouse and
they had them there and they they had
a pound for 40 dollars and then you can
add another half pound for 15 bucks.
So I cut a pound and a half for the fries
and it tasted pretty much exactly the
same.
You could tell that it came out like when
you pulled it out it was like a little
sweet little harder.
I guess.
Nice buttery mushy as the plate
but still tastes exactly the same.
So you think they just overcooked it.
Maybe.
I think they're frozen obviously you
know that you could try to tell they did
well I think they're all frozen quite
honestly because they're coming from
Alaska.
Well I was thinking that's why when the
morning sucks I was like Oh that place
probably gets it.
Yeah.
Well they just know how to
fucking do everything right.
There's certain places like you know
Morton's there's that other one Flemings
you ever heard of Flemings.
Yeah.
There's a whole chain of those things
they just know what the fuck they're
doing.
You know they sexually work
at Ruth's Chris Steakhouse.
Wait a minute hold on a second.
I.
I know what you said but I
thought I sexually worked
at Ruth's Chris Steakhouse.
That's why I heard you say
that stuff.
I was like.
I mean what the fuck did he say.
And that places and then I realized there
was a slurring or a I used actually I
sexually.
So I say I used to actually sing as
well you know if you ever heard someone
speak in another language and there was
a little there's they're just rattling
off and you if you don't know what they're
saying you could never discern that
there's more than one word going on
that you don't know when one stops at
another one ends.
That was a classic example that I used
to actually you know that's what does
that.
That's not a word.
It's like a Jeff Dunham bit or something.
No not Jeff Dunham.
What's his name.
I might be a redneck guy Fox or Foxworthy.
Jeff Foxworthy doesn't have a dad like
dark here like like things he would write
down like D G E 80s DG.
It's.
Like you know there is like
red and a redneck vocabulary.
Have you ever seen that show Swamp People.
Well they just alligator hunting.
Holy fuck man.
I'm only going to buy
alligator shit anymore.
I buy like alligators so I buy
like alligator skin things.
When I was a little kid an alligator he
displayed his dog and I'll never forget
that I lived there.
I lived in Gainesville Florida and
there was a place called Lake Alice and
there's alligators.
You see him all the time.
And I didn't think nothing of it because
nobody was scared until one of them at
this lady's dog I was
like Oh you motherfucker
but when you watch these people on these
shows these these alligator hunting
shows first of all you realize how many
fucking alligators there are because
they're killing a shitload of them.
You know they have like
a tag that they can fill.
I don't remember what the guy
was saying but it was like Oh.
I think it was like 500 or something.
Let's find out.
Alligator tag limits in Florida.
We didn't talk.
How was it being in Texas during all
that fucking bomb shit and raised
fertilizer things and crazy crazy.
We we we will miss the fertilizer thing
cause I was only there for one day but
that the bomb shit all of it is just
the whole thing is when it was something
like that happens.
It's so fuckin scary you know Katie
waitress Katie from the Comedy Store.
Yeah.
Her cousin's like look
at this photo right here.
Here's the terrorist guy
right here in the hat.
This is him dropping off the bomb.
Yeah.
Because this is the restaurant and he's
walking the opposite way to the he must
just dropped it off right there right.
Here's supposedly the kid that died.
Oh God.
Here's her cousins all right over
here and they all lost their limbs.
Oh God.
And so they're gonna have like a benefit
show soon but that's just a crazy
picture though because it
has it all and all together.
What the fuck man.
No one knows what any motive yet.
Where we're at now in the news.
It's all purely speculation because the
brother's dead and the youngest brother
is he got shot in the throat Apparently
kneeling ways communicating is writing
things down.
Here's something I just understand.
And of course there's a million people
online that are shouting out false flag
false flag the government trying to
take out our weapons away and tight down
security and that's why
that's why this is happening.
Did you read the kid's Twitter
like I stayed up all night.
Sure yeah.
Twitter was spooky.
I didn't see it.
Yeah.
His to his Twitter was
really spooky it was weird.
It seemed normal day but then he would
throw in like little things like fuck the
police and then or something
like Mohammed something.
Well I think if you're going to paraphrase
a guy he's a fucking murder or the
least he could do is go to his Twitter
page you lazy and actually read the
night.
I'm not my greatest guy.
That's what he said.
That was one of his tweets.
Yeah.
He goes on mostly kind
of a stress free guy.
This is after he had blown people up.
Yeah allegedly.
Of course this is the kid that
survived the one that's dead.
There's all these disputes
about what happened to him.
Some people are saying
the cops ran over him.
He's saying his brother ran over him
the whole thing sounds like and
people are crying out conspiracy.
One thing you have to realize about
information whenever there's a tragedy or
whenever there's anything that's like
really scary like this you know there's a
terrorist bombing.
It's people panic and you get a whole
bunch different versions of the truth.
And it's not a conspiracy
a lot of times it's just.
No one knows what the fuck is going on.
Everybody's terrified and stories spread
very quickly like they thought at one
point in time that one of the suspects
was a missing University student from
Brown.
And he was believes an Indian young man
and his family had been looking for him
for like a month and they distributed
this video and people are saying this is
one of the suspects.
This is really what happened.
You become like a jihadist and left.
But that wasn't true at all.
By the morning we found out it
was a totally different person.
So this is not.
This isn't like a conspiracy
to like hide that information.
And I think that's really important when
when people are looking at events like
this we'll wait till the dust settles
don't just start fucking calling out
conspiracy and calling out red flags and
false flags saying that it's some you
know nefarious thing going on.
Whatever it is is horrific.
But jumping on the immediate conspiracy
bandwagon is like Man that is one of the
worst things for the cause
of questioning things.
And if you ever wanted to be a good
disinformation agent what you do is the
moment that anything happens.
Start yelling and screaming
it's a conspiracy and expose
every single aspect of
it.
That you you feel is corrupt.
That would be the best way for the
government to protect themselves from any
thoughts of being labeled you know as
being a part of a conspiracy because
there's so many nutty people that do that
with every single event that it's like
they've cried wolf you know.
Yeah
I was so nervous with Greg Fitzsimmons
that night because he was actually down
there doing shows and I texted him and
he said that the shows were canceled he
uses in his bed watching movies.
Yeah shows your accounts.
Oh that one night don't know if it was.
Was it Friday night.
That was he flew all the way down there.
Yeah that was it was crazy man.
Friday night I was what was even
crazier is how horrible CNN was.
There were like an hour and a half behind
but then you'd like Look was it has to
have Watertown that jam gave me.
It was just like guys throwing grenades.
This happening this happened like
it was so insane reading that.
And it was also.
It was amazing how censored everything
was or delayed it was on the news.
It's like you think you know that shit's
you know people are getting grenades
thrown and that would be on
the news immediately you know.
But they were just like talking like oh
you know we're still looking for this
guy.
It's incredible everybody's a witness
now and everybody's a cameraman now.
Like what.
What's happening is you know people
on the streets can beat the news.
Yeah because they're right there too.
You also don't get a filter meaning you
don't get anyone correcting it either.
So it's interesting because you get you
get instantaneous news but you don't get
it vetted.
No it doesn't.
People don't make sure that everything
that's coming through is kosher.
Not to the news always
get it gets it right.
They don't.
And I guess it's better to do it that
way where it eventually sorts itself out
but the people that would step in
and sabotage that process and create
disinformation like a government agency
could be pretty fucking successful at
doing that I think and there's probably
a bunch of people that are hired to do
that shit all the time.
I've been accused of it myself but
I will tell you that is incorrect
and that I think like in those Starsky
and Hutch movies like when someone would
say one or TV show or any any cop show
these to have to remember in the old days
like someone would say if you're a
copy of tell me like when someone's an
undercover cop.
Oh yeah and mirrors
like a secret password.
Yeah.
You got to ask him Are you a cop.
I think Oh shit.
Yeah I'm a cop.
Yeah and I'm too smart for you Jack.
You can't buy this heroin.
You know there was like some magic word
I think that was a creation of fiction.
Yeah yeah I think they changed that.
Yeah
but people always thought that.
But you know that's that's probably some
disinformation the cops put out there.
There was an accusation recently that
the DEA put out a false paper about them
not being able to track people by using
a message because I messages over the
Internet.
And so there was like an article like
and I'm like a tech site like if you're
planning to sell drugs like
do it through I message why.
Because the DEA says it can't read it.
And then you know the DEA is pressuring
Apple but it turned out that was fake.
There's like the DEA made that just
get a bunch of assholes that are drug
dealers you know your dog just I message
me I don't know what accent that is if
that's your nationality.
I apologize.
It was just a spur of the moment thing.
I mean no disrespect but you know like
the DEA made a they put out fake news to
trick dummies into using
a message to sell drugs.
It's a good idea.
It is it's very crafty but it's one of
those things where it gets to the point
of you know when that's
not total entrapment.
That's just lying.
But what happens when you have undercover
people when you have undercover people
involved those undercover people sell
you coke and then you arrest them.
That's crazy.
You know why it's crazy
because there's no real Coke.
OK.
You're not selling coke
you're arresting them.
So you're saying that they wanted to
buy coke but you weren't even really
selling coke.
You just got them to act through the
moments to get point and get out and talk
through it.
There was no coke to buy.
There's no crime to commit.
They might have thought they were going
to commit a crime but there was no real
Coke.
They're not really buying anything.
Not really selling anything.
There was no real transaction
to fake transaction.
You're playing make believe.
And that's fucked up because you're
also trying to arrest people because the
more b b arrest the
better your career looks.
So it becomes a quantifiable thing so
you can talk someone into doing something
illegal and then arrest them.
And then it helps you.
But that's crazy because people
talk people in the suck their dick.
People talk people into doing all sorts
of stupid shit they didn't really want
to do.
They just did because they got
persuaded people could be persuasive.
So if you're some crazy sociopathic
Fuck that just so happens to be an
undercover cop and you want to talk
people into doing shit for you so you can
arrest them.
We need to put you in a cage OK.
You you crazy fuck yeah.
Tony.
Yeah.
You saying I'm an undercover cop.
No.
How do you guys find out about that.
Well the Internet is one of the first we
had to vet it but we just figured we'd
run it by first.
See how you reacted.
Well you know I have to tell you
once you bring it up it's true.
I'm an undercover cop.
You know it's just the whole idea that
they can pretend to buy drugs from you
and then arrest you.
It's like what are you doing with it.
Why did you go get it.
Stop.
Stop that.
You're selling fake drugs
you're buying fakes drugs.
Stop it.
Just cut the shit.
Stop trying to trick people.
OK.
Easy catch me.
Don't stop playing games
pretending you're criminals.
If you catch me don't.
Jesus Christ can we be everybody be
superhero superheroes dump tend to be
undercover drug lords and sell your
fucking illegal guns then arrest you.
Yeah I think with the drugs it's good.
I think they should keep you on
that predator thing now the drone.
No.
Get those guys to catch a predator like
bust and the guys that are trying to
hook up with kids and stuff.
Oh yeah.
That's different.
Predator drones a couple of kids.
Yeah.
But even that.
You know what.
Let's talk about that is like what
have you got like a really weak dude.
And he's a pedophile and he's gone
through like you know counselling and he's
got like all this you know shit that's
heavy in his head but he's gonna figure
out a way to never abuse again like he
got out of jail and he's trying to go
through counselling he's
trying to straighten himself
out and then along comes
the fucking to catch a predator show
and they just troll his ass off.
I don't know how they get people to
get into their site and chat with them.
Shit like I don't know
what those people say back.
I don't know what they
get to say back but.
Well sometimes you know they have the kid
being extra teasing it is sort of like
Hey there's a party plugged up I'm
having a party and making cookies.
Can you bring some sweet tea.
Although a sweet tea house was
sweet to southern most sweet tea.
Me too I suck dick.
There's there's there's some cookies
on the table I'll be right up and then
that.
What's his name.
Chris Hansen.
Powerful Chris Hansen.
How many crazy people that guy I met.
Do they still do that or not show.
I don't think so.
I think they got in trouble I think.
I don't see a lot of what they did.
First of all I think you have to get
people to sign releases to air that stuff.
I don't know how they got
anybody to sign a release.
I mean I haven't really considered news.
Maybe it's like look I don't know.
I mean how did they do that.
If you're audibly they probably cover
their costs their lawyers everything.
What if they really.
Oh yeah.
Because it's worth it to
them to have a helmet.
We're just totally speculating all
of and you know better than anyone.
So why don't we look that up real quick.
Let's see how to catch a predator.
Many thanks to Google.
How did you catch a predator.
Get them sign waivers.
Sure.
Watch what what you Google man.
You don't want that in your right.
Yeah no kidding right.
Hey what was up with you
in the Google glasses man.
I saw.
I'll tell you.
Just call me honey.
Honey honey sweetie pie.
How did kids get them to sign waivers
yeah you could get in trouble for like
looking too much into Catch predator like
what he tried to avoid being busted.
You know I was thinking about that the
other day like how do you even know
what's going on if you can't do certain
things like I was thinking of looking up
like how to make a bomb.
Just to see if that's out there.
Like nobody knows if that's out there.
If you don't google it and
everybody's afraid to google it.
Makes sense.
Yeah.
Did you do it.
No I didn't.
I don't want anything to happen.
Which is why I think I left an impression.
You know something.
I was curious about.
I wish there was a thing you could
google where it's like I don't know.
I just don't get it but it
seems like any crazy kid.
I don't know
the Internet's power.
The scariest thing about shows like
catch predator is you see that these guys
are like broken you know you see they're
like horrified when they get caught.
You see they know that it's fucked up.
It's not like these remorseless cold
insensitive unfeeling you know they're not
scared when they get caught
these guys fall apart.
You see they're horrified at who they are.
It's really it's scary scary to say
because it's like a glimpse into madness.
You know that guy Chris Hansen.
I guarantee you.
Now this sounds like some hippie bullshit
but being around people that are that
fucked up on a regular basis
and broadcasting them and
paying your bills based
on broadcasting them and all and I mean
like under the guise I guess you're
pulling these people off the street
and that's always a good thing.
Well you know what happened to him right.
What was it.
Was that he got caught cheating on his
wife or something I got some big media
thing.
Then he got investigated with a camera.
He was out with another bomb.
Me.
Look I don't know what the fuck
the guy's marriage was like.
You know I don't want to.
Crack on the guy for that.
I think there's a big
difference between that.
And you know of course you know some.
Pocket child some consensual.
Shit he did with Secretary whoever.
That freak is.
Oh I hate him for that but being around
all those people that were kid fuckers
man.
That's gonna wear on your soul that's
going to wear in your soul did you even
see these people over and over again and
being in their presence when you know
most of them are probably I mean I guess
this isn't their first time I would I
would assume this isn't the first time
they probably already had sex with young
kids or any so you watch.
It's just it's it's just it's really
it's gonna be a really depressing view of
the world and it's only so many different
things you can expose yourself to in a
24 hour time period and you got you know
365 of those 24 hour time periods in a
year and you got a hundred of those
years if you keep your shit together but
most likely no.
And you're gonna spend time hanging
around pedophiles all the time.
And it's one thing if you're a guy and
that's your job pull them off the street.
But I don't I'm not exactly sure what
good it does making a show out of that.
You know I mean except scare the fuck
out of everybody and make us aware.
But I feel like you know not that I mind
them being outed because it's such a
heinous crime against humanity.
But
man it seems like a fucked
up thing to broadcast.
You know it's like what do
we want to concentrate on.
It's one thing to like work on cleaning
that up but as a piece of entertainment
programming you're gonna you're going
to concentrate on someone who wants to
victimize children and you're
just gonna focus on that a lot.
I think it was a hit because you
know they're the ultimate bad guys.
Well you know you're looking at
the villain of all villains right.
No matter how fucked up
your own life is right.
Right.
Yeah.
Nobody's lower than a child molester.
Everybody can go that fuckin piece of
shit that fuckin p has to be on the couch
picking your fat toes.
Smoking a cigarette.
You see they're just picking dry skin
and your toes and just drop it on the
floor of this motherfucker.
That piece of shit I hope he
writes I hope he writes in jail.
Death is too good for him.
I hope he rot in jail.
You know what they do to child molesters.
They get him in their persons fucking
wretched stupid human being is barely an
ape.
They get the shit on this
child molester and feel better.
That voice grosses me
out the bastard later.
I feel bad I and do it from Boston and
Boston is in a bad position right now.
Oh just don't you know this Boston thing.
When one of the things that is fascinating
is that they like there was a thing
about how they weren't going
to read him his rights and then
this you know this thing about how whether
or not they were going to try him as
an enemy combatant or
try him as a civilian.
It's really fascinating that
that's becoming like a real issue.
You know the way they decide to approach
it like is this guy an American that
we're gonna try as an American you know
or someone who lets someone when someone
commits any form of terrorism.
Are they are they instantly
just out of the club.
Or do we try him as one of us you know.
Is it or is it a war thing.
Are we at war.
How we gonna how we're
going to go forward in this
Yeah it's interesting.
It's once it's interesting
the way we label things.
You know and it's interesting.
OK.
Any conspiracy theory aside that all these
nutty ideas that are floating around.
One thing we know for sure
there was bombs that a person put in
place that killed a bunch of people that
didn't do anything wrong.
And we have to figure out how the fuck
that happens and I know that sounds super
simplistic but as a human as a species
that's evolving clearly as we were
talking about the Mongols earlier and
like what they used to do a thousand years
ago like our most heinous acts pale in
comparison to those of our ancestors.
But when something like this happens you
realize that people are still capable
of such embarrassing ruthless
stupidity arrogance and just horrific
insensitivity towards their fellow man.
The idea that you could just take a bunch
of people you don't know and kill them
and maim home and just you just were in
the wrong spot at the wrong time and I
got a message and there's only one thing
that gets people to do that Fox by the
way and that's an ideology right.
It could either be a
religion or could be a cult.
Or it can be you know some group that
you belong to that sworn allegiance to a
certain code or set of rules.
But that's the only way you get people
to do shit like that if they don't have
an ideology.
They just don't do that.
Doesn't make sense.
There's no evolutionary benefit to doing
that other than pleasing a group of
other like minded psychopaths
someone you have to be
amongst a group of people that have very
specific beliefs that above all else
take precedent.
So that you're willing to put your
humanity aside for your crazy beliefs in a
completely irrational display of
destructive power and that you can kill
innocents.
That only comes from ideology
and we get really lost.
When we start talking about religious
freedom and religion and you know an
atheists are guilty of this just as much
as really religious people are because
whether you call it being a Muslim whether
you call it being a Buddhist whether
you call it being a vegan whether you
call it being a Christian whether you call
it being a Republican whether you call
it being a Democrat whether you call it
being a progressive when you lock
yourself in anything you become a part of
something that's almost
been decided for you.
You you you you you lock
into a pre arranged set of
opinions on things and some
of them are bat shit fucking crazy and
just like the Mongols got a hundred
thousand mother fuckers to roam across
Russia and Europe and China and slaughter
millions of people.
You can't do that unless you've got a
cause you can't do that unless you're part
of a group.
You can't do that unless your group
is separate from the other groups.
And the only way that ever works is
someone's got to talk you into that shit.
You've got to be a part of something.
And with this kid apparently was or he
was you know the one they're saying did
it he was a pretty radical
religious young man.
Now whether or not that's true.
Who knows science.
It has to be it seems to be the one thing
that all these people have in common.
Yeah well I think the false flag people
are thinking that like somebody gave
them all this stuff and that they were
talked into doing it and then it was a
plan to erode civil liberties that they
would sacrifice a few Americans and
clamp down on laws.
And this is this really is classically
what military leaders have been doing
since the beginning of time.
You know like we're talking about armies
in the past would actually sacrifice
soldiers and slaughter them so that the
rest of the people could eat you know
they would cannibalize themselves.
That was they.
They had to talk somebody into
doing something like that.
You know I mean
the first time somebody says
that's super awkward Yeah.
It's fuckin you know it's hard to believe
that in this day and age with the like
if you look at like how amazing
humans are capable of being you know.
Like here's a perfect example Oprah now
I know Brian doesn't like my love for
Oprah.
I love that you're I
Oprah I think it's Brian.
He goofs on me but it's
an honest appreciation for
what she does because Oprah
like you know I have a friend who worked
for and is like man she's like super
yuppie bitch.
Barely an hour and how the fuck are you
going to try to be a standup comedian
you can't even go two
hours without paying.
My friend was like he worked
for and he was like pow.
She's like intense you know.
You know she's like really.
She has an idea what she wants and she
gets done and you know he was like I
think he's been intimidated by too because
he was working for but like stop and
think about how much nice that lady
does like that lady is like so nice.
All those women that come
to her show they feel great.
Everybody leaves positive.
I was reading this thing the other day
on negative energy and that there was
some sort of a study that actually showed
that negative energy is contagious.
If you find out you know if you if
you're hanging around people that are
negative it doesn't just affect you when
you communicate with them and becomes a
part of the way you communicate as well.
It becomes contagious and one like super
aggressive contagious negative person
can actually infect like a company.
I think that's why it's important that I
mean companies have been really focused
on that.
I think ones that are really aware
of the social structure within the
organization they want to make sure that
you don't get like a really negative
Downer type person in any sort of a role
because if you get them you know that
they can really infect.
Like if they're especially if you had
some guy like you work on a big project
you got some one guy who's leading and
he's a douche bag and everybody shows up
work like oh it's there's very few things
in life worse than being stuck like
working in a job it sucks
with a boss who's an asshole.
Right.
Why do why are all bosses mostly
assholes to me making my list.
I look back at all the jobs I've ever
had you know and it's the majority like
they were always the assholes they were
never the people you hung out with or
wanted to hang out with you know they're
always there I was always a terrible
employee.
So I think anytime a boss got
mad at me I totally deserved it.
There was a shitty.
I did a shit job mowing lawns when
I was a you know a lot landscaper.
I remember the guy hired me to fuckin
scalped this law and I did not work a lot
more.
I lied just like you get
the job like my friend did.
And you said you could do it easy so
often it's not hard but it was hard.
The first time I did it was
kind of hard to figure out.
These are old shitty lawnmowers you
know and I sculpt the shit out his lawn.
You fucking hate most don't you hate it.
That used to be torture.
It's not it's it's not easy.
Oh yeah but when I was in high school my
friend Chris he one of the things about
Boston about growing up in Boston.
Boston is like a really in G.
They have a lot of ingenuity.
There's a lot of like
people get shit done.
So like it's a strong work ethic.
They're like clearly way stronger work
ethic than I ever experienced here in
California.
Like people are so used to getting up
in the morning shoveling their car out
from the snow they're used to shit like
it's a different kind of like there's a
different kind of like mentality there.
You know if you grow up there you go
and figure out what we're talking about.
I had an example where we talked
about just before that Boston yes fuck
I had a point and I completely lost
it and trying to figure out why it is
S.A.
after burying it.
I didn't.
I took it but not until
right before the show.
Fuck mowing lawns.
Oprah.
No no no I was passed over dude.
It was the the mowing lawns
things about oh my friend Chris.
Okay.
When I was in high school this is what
it was when everybody else was like you
know I had a job like Poppa Gino's and
shit I was like making spaghetti and I
was like pretty easy boring job.
This kid had a lawn mower empire.
He had a landscaping empire.
He had a brand new car.
He had people working for him.
He had lawns that were going
while he was at school.
He had guys working farm.
They were cutting lawns wise at school
and he would come home and he would go
and work till nighttime and they'd
show up for work the next day.
He always have new sneakers on.
He was like a grown man.
By the time we were 17 this fucking kid
I had never been around more people.
That made me feel like a lazy bitch.
There was so many dudes like my friend
Jimmy that I used to love Jimmy to tell
yo this guy.
Like he had from the time he was in
high school he had his own electrical
business.
He worked for a guy for a little while.
Started doing work on the same time he
got at a high school just got his own
business bus and asked 10 12 hours a
day drive it all out ran like a maniac.
It was you while you're around people
like that like you you develop that sort
of you know that sort
of tenacity that exists.
Like not a lot of spots
in this country you know.
And I think that dealing with like
environmental conditions there's something
about that.
It's why people from New
York tend to be funnier.
You know people from Boston tend to be
funnier because they're dealing with so
much bullshit all the time.
Definitely and controls.
I definitely think where you're coming
up with that raised has a lot to do with
that type of crazy factor of
your communication skills really.
I think it's down to like you know
small talk if it's the city that you're
raised in.
It rains a lot.
You're going to end up having to talk
with your friends more or if it snows a
lot if it rains a lot
if it's a windy city.
Things like that.
It's true.
And I think to be indoors or really apply.
Yeah.
Socially for sure.
Right yeah.
In California you could
sleep outside and live right.
I drank I drank.
Tom Hardy didn't talk on the
porch was smoking cigarettes.
That's a Don't you think that Ohio of
today growing up in the same place where
you grew up would be very
different because the Internet
because kids growing up
with the Internet be a lot more tolerable.
That's for sure.
Yeah right.
Yeah.
That's a totally different world now.
The whole world also got lights turned
on everywhere lights turned on and the
news started showing up
all the information started
flowing whereas before you
relied on local newspapers
and fuckin TV news.
Bitch how the fuck did you know what was
going on anybody know what was going on
then man.
How did anybody know.
So I think they're saying that there's
like certain laws that apply to
pedophiles.
That's why these guys were
allowed to be put on that show.
And there's a reason why they quit.
The guy killed himself while filming it.
One of the suspects somebody tweeted.
Well if they were being honest
when they say good riddance.
See you next week.
Yeah.
Show it.
I mean are they trying to get rid of
predators and trying to catch him.
It's not.
It's bad if they commit suicide.
Well we're all God's creatures
even the ones that fuck kids.
What I mean what is that.
That's ridiculous.
Well they got sued for one
hundred and five million dollars.
Why don't they just come clean and give
the guys have gone on the show and go
listen sir there's a bullet in
that gun put it up to your head.
Fuck this trial.
And that would be we'll
pay for your funeral.
Well you know they'd be
the most watched reality.
And then as soon as he
blows his brains I go sigh.
Film it.
Get a close up on him or we're out.
Get out of there.
Just leave him there.
Put it on TV no one's gonna know.
What are they gonna do.
They are the cops gonna sue NBC.
They're gonna bring
him in for questioning.
Look you saw what happened.
God fucks kids we gave him a gun.
Okay we're cool.
We're good here right here.
Would that be illegal I would say yes
especially if the guy didn't have a gun
permit.
Yeah I guess it really
depends on the gun law.
Yeah well maybe you could do it if you
gave me a gun and said Whatever you do do
not shoot yourself in
the head right now on TV.
You will smile a wink huh.
There was this weird comic at
the at the store last night.
Do you remember this Tony.
There was some Norwegian comic that I
did something about Michael Jackson or
something.
But he had this huge Wikipedia that just
goes off about how brilliant this guy
is and how much money how did he
write his own Wikipedia is with me.
But I mean he is connected to it like
a lot of these TV shows and stuff.
But anyways his wife comes up to me
goes Hey Fat Man come you fat man.
And I was right in front of my target.
And she was trying to tell
me that she wanted that.
That he has a nice house up here and he
pretty much she was trying to get me to
come back to them how their house for an
origin for what it seemed like and she
wanted you.
Well it's probably what they feel
like Hollywood's about right.
Yeah.
And he's like if I am going to make
it here you have to give up the pussy.
Listen we need orgies all of the time.
Norway only way to make
it as comedians so weird.
Yeah that's that's a pretty
odd story there fellow.
And then and then she's showing
me these photos and her phone.
She's like look at the parties we have.
And it's just like her and this other
girl like know women she's a comedian.
No no no she's the wife of the one she's
just like going around the whole place
like bragging about her
husband how many million.
Yeah she was she was very cute but this
guy looked like a bear and you know he's
a bigger guy with a suit that's like
four sizes too small we're probably both
CIA guys you got slowly worked there
is slowly gonna make it into the
organization.
DAVE There were looking into
this whole death squad thing.
You know like with his death
squad we have to worry about them.
We'll see.
See you you're the guy that they
wanted to take up there and show them.
Yeah.
Sure.
You're going to drug you and hit
you with some fucking some hypnosis.
Europeans just they just
don't have like normal sex.
He's going to be some Manchurian
Candidate type 2 that's going to happen.
CIA do is going to drop
a nano pill in his drink.
That's silly bitch.
He'll be hammered.
He'll drink anything to send his way.
You know with all the waiters that lady
that drives around in that pink Corvette
that's all yesterday.
This was my night Yes
sir excuse me last week.
This was my point that I see her maybe
once a week and it's always random places
like I'll see her in Hollywood
once I hear a lot around here.
But like that you just need
to tell people what she is.
She used to be like a rich wife I
guess that would post photos or these
billboards like all over.
Just kind of promoting her and
I don't think she really had.
Well that's one way to describe.
Yeah.
I don't think she really
had anything going.
She just had a lot of money to play with
and so she pretty much made her seem
like she was a big deal when she
really wasn't used as a rich wife.
Yeah well the billboards
were these giant billboards.
See Angelina on them in like big
letters like whoa it's Angelina.
And she's this really
pale lady with giant tits.
Yeah and she looks a little
odd like she looks like.
Like really like photo shopped.
Like really like brightly lit like it's
really hard to discern like key features
because she's apparently she's very old.
And when I came to L.A.
in 94 she had big
billboards all around town.
Like several of them that said
Angelina it was just her and then her
management's number.
It was her in her underwear.
It was really high.
Yeah it was kind of crazy
because you know she was.
She had a really nice body I guess.
Yeah.
Back in the day.
I do that.
Yeah.
And that's like.
What's her face.
Dolly Parton.
Yeah.
But by the time she was doing this I
mean who knows how old she was in that
picture but the the one that you
see today bears no resemblance.
Yeah.
I had no idea who she was.
And we were shooting something
at Hollywood Highland
one night and that crazy
like area and all of a sudden she
pulls up and people were like Oh my God
there's Angelina.
And it took I had no idea who this
was and it took it like four people 20
minutes to be able to explain to
me what the big thing was there.
Well I think she's in L.A.
she's like a..
Like an icon.
Yeah she's probably 60 years old at least.
She still dresses like she's like 75.
I've seen her several.
I wonder what she wanted if she
wanted to be an actress or like what.
Oh that's a good question.
Interesting marketing campaign.
But what's really weird is is
that how much I sear and jump in.
That's like one of the only cars
where you're like Oh that's her.
That's her.
Like how many times you actually drive
by people you probably know right and
drive around the same cars.
It's just so weird how small
Los Angeles actually is.
At that point you will in that sense and
you know it's also like the spots that
she hits the spots you're at like I
said I just saw the coffee being there.
That's what she looks like now.
Yeah yeah yeah man.
All right.
I'm sure she's a nice lady.
I mean you know I don't know
hate but you wouldn't do that.
No I mean look man.
Nothing wrong with being that you
know that's who she is she's fabulous.
Let her go get it.
Fuck this look.
Look that Brian put that away
all the way.
She's your grandmother man.
Show some respect.
I don't know if she's a mother or a
grandmother but you know that that whole
wanting to be famous
thing is a strange thing.
She was like one of the
original reality stars.
She created her own reality show
by just putting up billboards.
A reality show became her life you know
no one was filming it but her life was a
reality show.
You know I know she was I knew she was
a couple of years after living here.
So I've known who she
was since 96 ish 97 ish.
Wow.
I remember when she pulled up she had
her face covered with like some kind of
like one of those Asian aliens.
Yeah and shoot.
She was mysterious.
Yeah well
yeah.
That's uh that's a strange strange
world we live in my friends man.
If I was a porn star hot chick porn star
I would buy a pink Corvette and be her
new competition.
I'd be so rude.
You can call yourself Anzalone.
Yeah or Angelina.
That's a good idea though because I
mean that's how she got her attention to
seeing that you know pink Corvette the
money girl Angelina maybe you could have
like your whole thing was about like how
you get a rich husband who allows you
to freelance in your porn career and that
you know that will be the whole thing.
So the husband has no idea
what's going on he comes home.
What is happening in here.
Who are these guys.
And you explain while they were tag team
and you I'm got to say you know it was
all so I could get better with you honey
I just.
They're they're not tag team me.
They're teaching me this
is it's very controversial.
I should been.
Not going anywhere.
Have you ever been with a girl that
you're just completely haunted about like
that you think about like even after it
happened it was like Why the fuck did I
do that.
That's part of being truck son.
That's a whole part of being drunk.
That's a beauty of life.
If you didn't have those stories then
you wouldn't have those awkward moments.
And if you didn't have those awkward
moments you wouldn't have some really
hilarious shit to talk about when
everyone else is drunk as well.
I can understand what you're saying here.
That's what drunks have the best stories.
The being drunk drunk stories when they
could just really cut loose and be free
and not worried about it.
I have friends from back in the Boston
days of the best stories when they're
drunk and then somewhere along the line
those folks become alcoholics anonymous
people and all the stories stop.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm going to start getting
into alcoholics anonymous soon.
Speaking at the Comedy Store.
Going at comedy clubs so much you just
have to fucking during me and Tony battle
with this almost every single night
where we're like have you got a drink.
Yeah.
Because you know I mean it's just you
know what's interesting about you know
it's like either the night's going great
and you want to drink to celebrate or
it's a fucking boring night.
You want to drink to have more fun.
It's like there's never ever a time where
I'm just like in the middle like you
know.
I just said yeah we're
going to do it every night.
Have a show though man it
really can wear on you.
Well you know I'm very lucky because on
my end of it I'll sometimes only have a
half a drink or one drink because I'm
very little and I'm very reactive.
And so how many beers does
it take to get you fucked up.
Two and a half probably.
Yeah two and a half beers and fucked up.
Three I'm fucked up.
Great.
Yeah.
Three and I just decide to tell a story
that I wasn't sure if I was gonna tell.
Yeah I normally don't get to my
third during Ken till pretty late.
Oh really that's funny.
Yeah that's weird.
How much you weigh.
Probably about 127 right around there.
And if you think about
a beer is what a pound
right.
Yeah I guess so.
I'd say subtle of Jack Daniels fucks
me up essentially you get to like one
percent of your body weight fairly
quickly 1 percent by weight in beer.
Oh that's interesting.
Yeah.
Would you say what about Jack Daniels.
I've gotten to the point where I think
one bottle of Jack Daniels would fuck me
shut up son you fucking start
slurring when you open the cap.
Larry slurring in and then alive.
Sometimes I feel like I'm talking about
like bleeding from the liver until I
expire.
Yeah it's interesting that no one's
figured out a way to create the effect of
alcohol without the horrific
effects to your fucking body.
Well gee you know my way works.
You could just get down to one hundred
and twenty seven and just sip on a drink
all night long.
Feel great or black out every night
because you keep forgetting nearly one sex
sounds now right.
Like you imagine it like a guy
like Tate would take could.
Well he doesn't drink but in his prime.
Big guy you know the guys
can put away more like Joey.
Joey could put away some
fuckin booze at the wedding.
Joey
Joey barely ever drinks but when
he does he always gets the most.
He said so cute that you'll get
like I got an orange cream sickle.
He was a good man.
That's why you know people
like pina coladas and shit.
Yeah yeah.
Fucked up and some folks only allow
them that on when they're on vacation.
But men.
Well when men are drinking
they weren't manly shit.
They want something that is mixing up.
Oh yeah right.
Talking about here's one drink right now.
I have a long night of drinking.
Don't be a pussy.
You're saying you rather drink
with them than drink with us.
No I mean how would you have you.
How dare you let me know what you have
because I'm pretty hung over right now.
Well I'm about to go watch
a fucking UFO documentary.
So I'm fixing you're fucked
up if only I can watch today.
I'm not really big on watching UFO
documentaries while sober there's a spray
something's gonna go wrong.
This jam van just showed me there's a
spray that gets you instantly drunk for a
few seconds.
Well that sounds awesome.
Seems super healthy.
You should give give that to yourself
right before you leave the house.
How long does it last.
It doesn't say just a few 5 seconds.
Is it like some limpets type shit.
Yes.
No.
I don't know what it is.
It's one spray releases.
Point 0 0 7 5 0 0
0 gets you drunk legally 0 legally drunk.
How would you show me that they got
some sportscaster some sportscaster got
pulled over for.
Is it Al Michaels.
I got pulled over and he was on the limit.
It was absent at the limit 0 8 and 0 9.
What happens then when you're out.
Here's a link.
Don't you first have to do the drug test.
You know like you walk around like a
buffoon and then if you fail that then you
have to do it.
He obviously I guess showed
signs that he can't do.
You know balance on one foot.
You know so.
Well not necessarily.
They might have just asked him and he
said he would take the test cause you only
had one drink.
That's what he's saying.
Saying he only had one drink.
I think that I read that note.
You know what.
That's what the I'm sorry.
That's what Reese
Witherspoon's husband said.
You got the wrong drunk.
He said he only had one job but the Al
Michaels guy he tested on the limit.
And he's a fuckin man's man.
He's a fuckin sportscaster.
He told me that guy doesn't know how
to drive when he's a little tipsy.
He's an 0 8.
Let him go.
You pussy don't you appreciate a good
game of hockey being called by the maestro
and he let him go.
It's not like you're
letting go of criminal 0 8.
Not something pro drinker
that's a pro socialized.
Like I've known him since he was a baby.
Yeah.
0 8.
The fuck out of here.
What a pussy society we have.
That's not drunk.
OK if he's drunk.
Yeah for sure.
Arrest him asshole.
That's ridiculous.
People driving around drunk are assholes
but people driving around that are
barely buzzed at 0 8.
Come on.
How do I know that your body functions
as good as mine does when I'm drunk.
How about that.
Your reaction time.
How good is your outlook.
How do I know you're not a dullard
without with a slow right foot.
You just can't get to that burger on time.
You know maybe Al Michaels could still
even eat whatever he is 70 and still do a
solid two step hits
that break like a champ.
Not saying he should drive drunk.
I'm saying what's 0 8.
Looks like a drink right.
Yeah pretty close yeah.
I would like to see what a 0 8
guy looks like performing stuff.
You know I wouldn't like
to see him go through that.
I would like to.
I'm sure he's always nowhere
when he's calling the Super Bowl.
You know what I mean bright you know.
You know one that doesn't count though
here's the thing though is the adrenaline
that you get when you get pulled over.
I would imagine that would have
some sort of a recuperative effect.
Like if you're a little a little driving
a little shitty cause you're kind of
hammered and you get pulled over and it
might jolt you into a position where you
could possibly perform the test a little
better than you could be but it's not
going to make you less drunk right.
So 0 8 is still in 0 8.
She blew it.
Yeah I think it's just entirely too low
to blanket that that's considered a DUI.
Because I mean you know if you go out
to dinner and you have a drink like a
margarita and a bartender like
cause it's stronger than normal.
Are you saying that just
having one margarita with
dinner you should go to jail
and you know get all these things on
your license that you think you know that
you're gonna run into a pile
into a school of children.
Like I don't buy that.
I think that's I think that's it.
I don't know I'm not a big fan.
I think aging needs to change.
I think that's a dosage issue where
you're talking about the dosage issue and
that they really should get in
trouble if they're doing that.
I mean people don't want to
get in trouble you go you go.
This proves the good the stiffest drinks.
You really should let people know what
the fuck you serve them and if you're
serving them some margaritas It's got
twice the alcohol in it you're trying to
get customers that way you could fuck
somebody up if they know exactly how they
usually rocket you know they have this
thing I'm good for one margarita and then
I back the fuck off and then
I get home and I'm fine.
And then also the guys hand driving on.
He doesn't know what happens because you
you say saying essentially like doubled
his dose.
Yeah I'm just saying
it's way too low I think.
Yeah but not to you.
I guess I see your point.
Definitely.
But I'm not convinced.
I don't have any data I want to see a
guy who's at a weight go through all that
shit.
Is it based on what percentage you are.
Your fine too.
You know I want to do it.
I want to.
I want not to get you guys together.
No.
No I don't want to.
That's one thing I've been really
careful about my entire life.
I think it's really important to be
safe when you're operating a vehicle.
I mean the idea that you would operate a
vehicle with your body all fuck in half
there.
That's so scary to me it's so scary to
be the driver it's so scary thinking that
so many people out
there that are doing it.
It's so selfish and stupid but I think
that I would like to find out what it
feels like to be at 0 8.
And do you know any of those
tests any of those lean.
I wouldn't know.
What is it like if they say like you know
I'm not gonna drive but get me to the
limit.
Give me a breathalyzer.
OK you're at 0 8 now.
Like whether it's three drinks or two
drinks and now make me do your stuff.
I want to know what it feels like.
Buy you can buy a breathalyzer
on Amazon you should do it.
I don't want to do it
because I don't want to.
I definitely don't want to drive by
but I would like to drive on a course I
would like to go on a course and see
like get me to 0 9 and let me see what I
can do.
I think you're gonna be surprised how
exactly normal you're gonna be feeling.
I wonder why I wonder because I've
been drunk and as of you I wonder.
I wonder what it's like to do that.
Well I would but then again like telling
people that 0 8 or 0 9 is the limit
means that's probably where most people
who are not in the best shape or don't
have the best talents for alcohol
where they start to falter.
So if you make it a public policy that's
probably a good idea to do it on the
conservative side you know ethnic humor
you had a fun funny thing was talking
about like it should really be based
on your tolerance and they should you
should have like a license that indicate
their tolerance but that shit changes
too.
Because dudes start falling apart.
Yeah.
You have to just take a license test
Sara tolerance test once a year.
It's so incredibly irresponsible
to tell people they can drink more.
Right.
You know they tell people that the
legal limit as is that you could drink a
little more.
Fuck just fucking green light.
I love that.
Yeah and God dance like me boy.
I got tolerance like.
I mean think about like
that my friend Justin.
Here's a perfect example.
You know my friend Justin said that seven
foot tall did not find Justin's like a
legitimate giant.
He's enormous.
And if you go drink for drink
with him you're gonna die.
If you're going to die you're
not the same species as him.
He's a completely different human being.
So it's like a dog next to a cat.
It's not the same time.
Pretty sure it's Andre the Giant
actually has a drinking record.
I'm serious.
I think he has some.
There's a drinking record
I think it's a crazy night.
And lawyers.
Wow.
But he was you know he's like
he's like seven foot something.
He was enormous.
Yeah.
There's been a few giants since
then that gotten mixed martial arts.
This is Guy giant Silva.
He was like a legit giant.
And he fought in pride.
And then there's Antonio
Big Foot Silva and that guy.
I think I'm seeing I think I'm saying
giant silver I think that's his name.
If not I apologize.
It's a big giant go crazy shaggy hair.
And then there's another guy semi shell.
He's like seven feet tall.
I think he's just a huge guy.
I don't think he has gigantism I think
he's just an enormous regular human but
you would just imagine a guy like conjure
the giant those little tiny you ever
see a picture of a little
tiny beer can in his hand.
Yeah.
To Tracy to trip he would
hold a beer in his hand.
I was like you hold on when those little
kids apple juices you know the ones
that come in lunchboxes.
Well this is that they estimated that he
drank over 7000 calories every day and
booze alone.
I wouldn't do that.
Do they have the sat
there the number with.
I know it's like a decisive thing.
Well I want to see the picture of
his hand because it's so silly.
You know Rowdy Roddy Piper started coming
by the comedy store a couple of years
ago and once in a while he'll swing in
and he's friends with a few of us there.
And man he's so great at
hanging out and telling stories.
And one of the stories that he
told us was about Andre the Giant.
Somebody was guys you know because they
did the road together for a decade or
right.
Right.
And he talks about how one time they were
at a bar and there were these college
kids like you know fuck
you Andre the Giant
that they're drinking beers at that
one time a kid drinks a beer throws the
empty can at the back Andre
the Giant said and he goes.
Don't do that again.
And then later on he takes an empty can
and he throws it at the back onto the
giant's head and they do
that and they all sure.
Oh my God.
And they all run outside.
Running away from Andre the Giant who
got up and is now chasing them and they
all got in their car all at once but
Andre caught up to the car before it drove
away and he just flipped.
He he picked up the coin
as you hear the story.
Rowdy Roddy Piper.
Really.
Yeah.
It's got to be a true
story too even if it's not.
Let's let him tell it.
Isn't that picture hilarious
though him holding the beer can.
I mean it's like a little bait.
It's like you ever see like a little
kids refrigerators that they would fake
refrigerator.
That's what looks like.
One hundred and nineteen
beers in six hours.
God that's what they're trying.
Yeah that's what he drank.
Yeah yeah.
How big was that guy.
What was his height and weight
7 1 7 foot 1.
And he wasn't just tall.
He was enormous.
Oh yeah.
God damn between 6 and 7 5 and over 5
some between 6 7 7 5 and over 500 pounds.
And then I also saw some that's a very
whole fucking they measure him right.
You know what the problem with that is
wrestling they lie you know six foot
eleven 3000 pound twisted steel you know
they lie just to make guys look bigger.
But that guy was like legitimately
enormous like in a real wrestling match he
would beat everybody.
I also heard a thing that that big body
slam that was like from the big wrestle
mania to where Hulk Hogan body slams
the ultimate bad guy Andre the Giant.
Right.
And it's like you could tell Andre the
Giant jumps into it with all his might
and Hogan's just trying to.
Yeah.
All he needs to do is go like that.
It's amazing that he
can even hold them up.
And he said that when he did that he
could feel every disc in his back just go
up up up up up up up up.
Hulk Hogan.
Yeah.
And then he laid down Andre the Giant
and he was just so glad that that was the
end of the match because
he he ruined his back.
Yeah.
His back is fucked up now right.
He's had surgery.
All these guys are.
Those guys are unbelievable warriors
because they were doing it every night and
sold out arenas.
You don't realize.
Right.
They had to put on a show.
They were going non-stop.
And like even Piper just like six or
seven months ago he was by the store.
He would come in like once in a while
every few days for you know just then.
Anyway he could.
He kept going Oh my shoulder saw my
shoulder so I'm going to the doctor on
Wednesday.
It's still worked out
for four hours today.
Well my shoulder saw Hannah finding out
that he had a technically broken his
neck.
A broken neck and the doctor's like it's
not your shoulder it's your neck and
it's broken.
So it was like pinching a nerve and
Ryder was hurting his shoulder right.
But he he's just.
These guys are so tough in real life.
That
is to hit on a sore shoulder.
Yeah.
What does people give a fuck
about wrestling anymore.
Oh yeah they're still there.
It's still very popular.
Unbelievable.
I keep seeing like C.M.
Punk and all these people and all the
pictures and been crazy is that you know
most people don't know this but like
Monday night raw for example which is the
premiere weekly show
someone's a wrestling fan.
Yeah but it's been number one on one.
It's held Monday nights forever.
Do you know this and why
the fuck do you know this.
I said I'm saying let's go on.
When I was saying when I was a kid
I was in a wrestling like that.
And then I grew up and go oh my gosh.
Yeah I can't believe you went there.
Me too and I still like wrestling
I'm still has pubic hair.
Dude stop being an asshole.
I don't.
I haven't watched wrestling.
What you're doing is
cyberbullying right now.
No I'm just I've been giving him a
hard time because they all had like a
wrestling party and I was there wasn't
we our buddy you got wrestling mania and
he has a giant screen and it's funny too.
You know we all do you
guys take our clothes off.
Yes.
Right.
Did you reenact the moves with lube.
Yes.
Hey what do you think
about this CSPAN thing.
The bill that passed the House
it's fucked up crazy scary.
If you guys don't know about the House
of Representatives passed Cisco which is
the Cyber Intelligence
Sharing and Protection Act
by a 288 to 127 vote and it's
the ideas supposedly that it's meant
to enhance national security by
facilitating sharing of
electronic information between
like this quote between
say a private company and the government
this is a story from media dot com and
the way they describe it is that if the
government like say if a private company
in the government deemed threatening the
bill's opponents maintain it will make
sharing of personal private information
far too easy so I guess the idea is what
is it what is the main the main idea
about behind this bill is that they're
going to be able to see every website
you've ever visited every Web site will
have a bill to share the information of
different people who have gone to them
that would just you know I have no idea
what the exact specific thing is but
yeah it seems like that's
what I was talking about.
But it isn't going to be vetoed by Obama.
I don't know because he didn't
have but he didn't veto the NDAA.
You know I mean Obama is a hilarious
kind of situation because he's super
intelligent he's half black he's you
know from a single parent household but
he's still like votes just
like the Republicans do.
He still does stuff that the
Republicans do like it's really strange.
It's like if he was a white guy people
would be fuckin furious if he was a white
guy of privileged background and he made
the choices that he's made as far as
like bailing out the banks as far as
passing the NDAA not vetoing in all these
different things that have happened the
drones all these different things that
have happened while he was in office.
If he was a white guy of privilege
he would be getting crucified.
It's fascinating.
It's almost like the perfect plan like
if you were a military strategist and
you're trying to take over the company
you would do it with a situation like
that you wouldn't just go get some super
elite rich guy you'd get some guy who
you would associate automatically with
progressive liberal sensibilities and
then you do all that creepy
shit right under his nose.
It's really interesting.
His big slogan was change yeah.
And looking back on it now it's like
well he changed a little you know drone
attacks went from 50 up to like
300 changed a lot in Pakistan.
It's not funny but fuck man.
I don't know it's uh it's it's just seems
like it if if he really could change
things.
If you really could like influence
this society and how is the time to do
something you know instead of just these
speeches sort of reactionary speeches
dealing with each and every issue
whether it's Sandy Hook or whether it's
whether it's this Boston thing like
wonder what if anything could be done to
sort of enact a
a change in a culture a plea
for for a change in a culture.
And if anybody could do that
it's got to be the president.
You know and the president addresses.
He does these national speeches where he
addresses policies and he addresses not
national affairs as far as
security affairs and then
threats and various things
along those lines.
But what this country's really fucking
needs they need of a different not not a
different person but a different mantra.
We need a new way of looking at things.
We need a speech.
We need something that gets people believe
and we need an I have a dream that I
have a dream Martin Luther
King's speech to this day.
That shit resonates.
No one's doing the I Have A Dream today.
Everyone's doing the.
We're all gonna get along and change
and hope and you know and make it more
affordable and healthcare for everyone.
And gay marriage.
But no one has a speech about uniting
humanity and getting us to understand that
our lives really are truly only better
when people around us lives are better as
well and that United
there's enough resources for
everybody there's enough love
everybody is enough nuff
health for everybody.
There really is.
It's just the current system in the
current ideology that we have is not based
on the reality that we're
an expiring lifeform.
And then we have a temporary time here
on this planet and to waste it not being
aware of the full reality of the situation
is a shame and a guy like Obama has
the opportunity to do that but he
doesn't ever say anything like that.
He never says anything that
really inspires people to
look at it in a completely
different way.
He never says anything
like I think you have to.
If you're in a position to be the fucking
President of the United States that's
a position with very few human
beings ever get to reach.
I mean maybe he will when he's leaving.
Maybe we will once he leaves.
Maybe you can't when you're there.
I mean who knows.
I mean maybe it really is an
incredibly restrictive environment.
And he has no room to free ball and no
room to go outside of what they want him
to distribute as policy.
I don't know.
Mean I don't know what the fuck the
situation's like but if this world ever
needed someone to speak up and someone
to just make some fucking sense someone
to make some sense and not talk politics
you know not talk religion just talk
humanity not talk nationalistic not
talk conflict just make some sense.
Well I guess this is the you know this
the same bill was vetoed last year by the
White House and it looks like you know
it just it's one of those things that's
just poorly written and
everyone knows that type thing.
So so is the India.
Unfortunately pass really
hard through Congress.
The thing is it didn't pass as
hard in Congress the first time.
Well I think that I read
something about it this morning.
A lot of the way the government set
up and I'm obviously not an expert on
government but I know that a lot of the
the way it's set up is that you know we
have representatives and you know we
can't all be there while policy is being
dictated so our representatives go
there and they make sure that everything
represents their constituents but clearly
a better way to do all that is the
internet.
If anybody had to be phased out.
Oh it's the majority of politicians
they're involved in making laws.
You could face those guys can
get all new jobs you know.
Have you seen House of Cards.
No.
She is awesome.
This show shows you what's
actually happening in
Washington following a real TV
show.
Oh somebody made up.
Oh it's unbelievable.
No shows you.
You realize what they're
what they're dealing with.
What they're actually doing
and it's all just it's.
Is it awesome.
It's all just deals.
The show's unbelievable I mean Kevin
Spacey already is a bad mother breaks the
third wall or whatever and just start
flicking at the camera telling you what
he's thinking in the middle of scenes.
It's pretty.
It's really great.
Oh it's the there's everyone else freeze
in the background freeze like they're
playing the game sort of pretty much.
There's
still still the you know they blur out
but then it's just him just know it'll be
a cross meeting table from somebody like
here's what I'm about to do and they
don't know it but here's
how I'm going to do it.
Watch this.
Oh and it's amazing it's
really just politicking.
You learn a lot about you know even show
business and networking overall from
how these politicians operate because
that's all that they're doing is playing
gossip games and texting and it's a
broken system and they're all criminals
keeping us from the Internet.
That's what it is.
They're trying to tighten down on this
fuckin system and what they don't want to
do is admit that this could all be
handled way better with voting online.
Let's do it that way.
Every person has an I.D.
every I.D.
is just like your fucking
social security card.
Yet only do it once boom
and you vote online.
Yep.
And when that happens
that's when things get good.
You can't control that bitch.
You can't you can't control that.
They'll deal.
They'll never allow something like that.
They will fight it till death.
That literally might be
where the revolution lies.
I is getting people to vote online because
they would essentially be giving up
all of their tricks but they've been
using over the past decades to manipulate
how ah ah ah.
People are picked how our presidents
picked how laws are passed and all that
shit has been manipulated everything
should be done the popular vote now.
Yeah.
Isn't it a fascinating idea
that there would so try hard.
They would try so fucking hard to avoid.
Yeah that would be like
a real tipping point.
This country will really realize
we're being run by vampires.
Oh yeah.
Like how quickly they would fuckin shriek
into the dark corners of the room when
you open the drapes and take a
good look at the real scenario.
Then I try to like give
the people what they want.
They're trying to profit
off the current system.
The current corrupt
system as in place got.
Tony you need to write your clean
young man you can run for president.
You're very likeable could
probably pull it off.
You think you could.
There was a period of time when I was a
kid and I wanted to but you wanted to be
president at one point.
Time for a little moment.
Did you fall on your head or something.
What made you want to be president.
How do you get sick.
We deliver now.
I thought it was just very very young.
I thought it was going.
Did you have the fever.
Yeah.
The president's fever.
He had the president's fever.
You know when we all go through that
score and sixteen you're lying in your bed
dying.
Yeah I got obsessed with.
There was a period where as a kid I was
obsessed with like the Declaration of
Independence and how it
came to be in like a hole.
I read it.
I remember reading a whole book about
John Hancock when I started practicing my
signature all the time.
I was obsessed with John and I thought
that was so cool that this guy had the
balls to be like here you
go here I am and I did this.
Who would be the first person to be
president that doesn't have the fake
president voice who'll be the first person
that just talks to everybody a person
who changes the world who doesn't have
a way of speaking with long vague pauses
when I believe what I believe for you.
And for me and for our great
nation is that we must unite.
Imagine if it is it's so bizarre that
fucking guy was over your house bitch why
are you talking like that.
Why are you talking this fake stupid
voice but you get away with that when it's
a big group of people
and you're a politician.
We know that you're talking in the
fake us most old school way possible.
You might as well be in
the theater you dummy.
It might as well be in the theater back
when they didn't have microphones when
they just have to shout
out their stupid lines.
Imagine a strip club deejay being the
president just shook up deejay with no
microphones coming up to the main stage.
It's time
and then a bunch of banjo players behind
have the music because you don't have
electricity do they.
I country at a bomb threat.
I got more information or more evidence
to the poor people that think that I'm
in league with the devil.
I wore this t shirt on Fox.
It was the Wild and Wonderful
Whites of West Virginia.
They when I ordered the DVD they found
out we talked about on the podcast so the
people that make it they sent me these
cool T-shirts and one of them was that
famous picture of Nixon meeting Elvis
leather shaking hands but they replaced
Elvis's head with Jessica White and Nixon
with the devil himself and says like
the devil and so just go and I wore nuts
on Fox and I got like a hundred tweets
go.
What the fuck are you wearing on TV.
I didn't even think about it but for a
good portion of this knucklehead country.
If you have a shirt on that has a
devil's face it says the devil like these
dummies actually think that you like
you're you're down with the devil like the
devil and that's what that's where we
draw the line in this kooky country even
even you know even religious people
like you can say that you believe in God
you're allowed to say that you even
want to say that God talk to me.
You know I saw a guy say that the
other day didn't even bother me.
There was a guy that was in Austin Texas.
There was a guy that was at a red light.
He was begging.
He had a cardboard thing.
And the guy in the car rolled
down the window said Hey man.
God just talk to me and told
me I should give you this.
And he gave the guy 20 bucks.
That doesn't bother me but if the guys
roll down that window it Hey man I was
just speaking to Satan and he thought
you could use this to party with me.
You're not talking to Satan
anybody believes in Satan
as an asshole like you're
allowed to believe in God.
But if you say you believe in Satan
everybody tells you to go fuck yourself.
You have to be like way deep
in cuckoo for cocoa pops.
Oh you actually believe in Satan to
believe in to believe in the bad guy.
Yeah.
Have you ever met someone who actually
believed in Satan and you didn't know
that they believed in Satan
until you got to know them.
I mean you know like shit I feel like
I've met a couple of people that really
wanted to be different.
And I couldn't pull it off though.
You know they don't have the commitment
I met a girl once and she was with her
sister and it was total
innocent conversation.
You know nothing nothing crazy.
God said it was totally normal and she
brought up something I think it had to do
with gay marriage.
I think it had to do with that and it
was something about a bill being passed
and it was many many years ago so my
memory's a little foggy but I do remember
this whenever the controversy was.
She said she goes it's not God's way.
And I said I remember like stopping
and like all the sudden going whoa what
would happen with this conversation.
Like what did you just say.
It's not it's not God's way.
How do you know what God's way is.
Do you do you really talk to God.
Like where are you getting this from.
And she goes Oh that's Satan's
his scales have covered your eyes.
She actually said that to me his scales
have cut and I'll never forget me
looking at her and her sister
and god damn you crazy bitches.
Yeah.
And the girl was.
She was so pretty too.
Oh my God she's beautiful.
She was like Latin or something
like Donald's like oh crazy bitches.
Well you guys take care.
Just guys I was like we can't even talk.
You really think they're like Satanist
scales and he puts it over your eyes.
We have so much work to do here.
I'm not taking on this project like to
just just to communicate with you and get
you to a point of rational
objective thinking.
We take three for mushroom trips right.
Have you heard of a guy named Pier Popoff.
He's a pastor.
He's televangelist guys.
What did he do.
Blow some money.
I saw him the other day I watched I was
sleeping on the couch and I woke up in
his head when the shows are not paid
shows commercials and I was amazed what
woke me up because I was kind of like
half listening to while sleeping.
What was amazing how the things that they
sang it just seemed illegal like they
were like you like oh you know we're
gonna sing you some miracle water.
This water is you know miracle water
you're going to open up these envelopes.
And then they start showing
Mike testimonials like a
people and they're like You
know I sent in my or I read the letters.
And then just a week later I got a new
house in a car and then the next person
was like I got two
hundred thousand dollars.
And then his other one like a guy just
walked up and gave me a check for 15
million dollars and it was it
was like the most fake shit ever.
And so then I started really researching
this guy and there's all these videos
about him online.
I guess he's been ripping people off for
a long time and one of the best videos
is one where he just goes up and he goes
where's where so-and-so so-and-so is
here.
Let's let's say Tina.
Tina Fey.
Where are you.
And then she comes up because I heard you
have arthritis and you're here because
you wanna get rid of this
arthritis and stuff like that.
Oh the whole time his wife is
just pumping the whole show.
Yeah.
She had a thing on it was on one of
those 20 20 Yeah I don't like that.
Yeah I know we talked
about this in the past.
I'm pretty sure maybe he's on another
podcast but I was amazed that he's still
allowed to do that.
Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Well that guy.
Well name one is not.
It's almost like it's.
That's so ridiculous.
It's like the most ridiculous hustle ever.
It's like Who are they.
Tricking the LNP with a trick and
are like they're almost like mentally
challenged.
Oh yeah.
People with no hope.
When you're when you're just robots
when you're down to being convinced that
there's a miracle water out there that
is going to come in the mail via the
postal service and it's going to it's
going to change your fortune right.
Yeah that's the one.
One of these things.
Somewhere along the line they used to ask
for donations but then somewhere along
the line they they realized that they
could sell things and they started like
selling like holy water and selling like
prayer services and and telling people
that you would plant a seed.
So if you spend ninety dollars
you Jill asked ninety dollars.
He would come back to you and tenfold.
The Bible says that would come out with
some crazy fucking was that the guy
Creflo Dollar.
He's my favorite because he's
got a dollar in his name.
I mean you're a pastor and
your fucking name is dollar.
What's your read.
They all have weird names like that.
Okay I guess it Good Peter Popoff.
Have you ever met any
other pop ups before.
This guy's got to have a
different real name now.
He must have a real name
what's his real name.
Wow his real name is Creflo
Augustus dollar Junior.
Wow this is real fucking name.
Can a Bachelor of Science and Education
Center talking shit smack in people.
My favorite Robert Tilden.
You know he is.
You've probably seen him.
There's a viral video of him farting.
Like he's like he talks in
tongues a lot on a show to Hugo.
Some like a chuckle love of my life
my life you know my you know my level.
It's hilarious.
See if you could pull up Robert Tilton
talking in tongues because it's some of
the most ridiculous shit ever.
But one I'll never forget this one thing
he said he said every time you write a
check to me Satan gets a black eye.
Wow.
But it doesn't part of you think that
if you're dumb enough to send him that
money like so what.
So a guy got you with the dumbest trick
of all time like you really thought that
money was going to gone.
You really thought that money is
gonna give the devil a black eye.
If you really thought that you're fucking
stupid or not looking after you right.
One of the Scott things
that this Peter Popoff does.
He also sends you a barley cake from the
Bible where it's like kind of like that
little bread you eat.
And he goes he goes in this commercial
he goes and we make it with the exact
ingredients that they say in
the Bible and blah blah blah.
Well then if you look up Ezekiel 412 in
the Bible it says and you should eat it
as barley cakes and bake it
using fuel of human waste.
So the human way.
So.
So wait a minute wait a minute wait.
No it doesn't.
You want that typing in a for 412.
OK easy.
That's a Larry.
Hey I.
Hold on hold on.
Easy E K E L E for twenty
four to twelve for twelve.
Yeah.
You're thinking about the we love but
he kill for twelve a long time since I
read up on my good old days he kills.
This is all new to me baking with Don
that comes out of man in their sight.
Hold it.
So he's saying hold on.
I can see our cooked fish.
Oh my God.
And thou shalt bake it with dung and
that comes out of man in their sight.
Well it's in the Bible it's in the Bible.
Why do you need to study the Bible
and cook you by hand with shit.
Have you ever tried my
poo poo barley cake.
Fucking imagine how dumb people are.
That really hurts my brain.
Do you know Ezekiel Zeke might have been
tripper because his ego was also where
the first depictions of UFOs came from.
He only pulled out.
Yeah Zeke Hill was known for.
There's there's a Bible quote that
people bring up all the time was a UFO.
But people were seeing a lot
of things after eating a shit.
Mainly they're eaten fucking shit cakes
all day throwing out almost dying.
It was a wheel within a wheel.
It was God sharing it.
There was guys with boats
they had all the animals.
You think we should prepare the
barley cake in a different way.
No no it's great.
I'm trying to find Jesus.
What a stupid fucking culture.
I cook it with shit.
Okay Dad should I write
that down on paper.
I put something in for violent my son
because I got so obsessed with this
minister that so when I found that out I
had tweeted something like Olive Garden
was like executive for 12 or something
like that and all these people got pissed
off that I was due to
doing Bible scriptures.
Oh that's hilarious.
Well they read that though.
Yeah they figured it out.
How do you not read that
and just start laughing.
Told me to cook shit cakes.
Fuck the Bible says Cook shit cakes.
That's just one more
dumb thing in the Bible.
God damn it I'm so tired of people
pretending that books are awesome.
I'm so tired you stop that shit stupid.
Okay here here's a here's a quote and I
looked and behold a whirlwind came out
of the North a great cloud and a fire in
folding itself in brightness was about
it and out of the midst thereof as the
color of Amber out of the midst of the
fire OK.
House audio file
hmm.
That's somebody putting
two points together.
They don't go together for oh
wait a minute this hold up.
And this also out of the midst there
of came the likeness of four living
creatures and this was their appearance.
They had the likeness of a man.
Whoa.
After everyone had four faces and everyone
had four wings and their feet were
straight and the sole of their feet was
like the soul of a calf's foot and they
sparkled like the color
of burnished brass.
What a trippy book.
People like Oh my God it's so real.
I hear God's words when
you're saying these things.
God is speaking to me through your words
please read on and they had the hands
of man under their wings on their four
sides and they had and therefore had
their faces in their ways.
Somebody might have just made all this
up and me like an asshole is reading this
fake Bible quote shitting all
over the Bible and the aliens.
But guess what.
I don't care.
I'm not reading any further.
It seems like if this is if this really
is as it kills it says it is God damn
it.
I think it's all nuttiness.
They walked up with their four faces
and they said Why are you guys cooking
things in shit.
And the living creatures ran and
returned as the appearance of a flash of
lightning.
Now as I behold the living creatures
behold one wheel upon the earth by the
living creatures with his four faces.
These guys were tripping hard eating shit.
Kingsley yeah losing their mind.
What grows on shit.
Mushroom that's right.
Leave your shit takes out
the cover with mushrooms.
Eat your shit cakes chip your balls off.
Stop talking nutty man.
When those went these went and when those
stood still these stood and when those
were lifted up from the earth
the wheels were lifted up.
That guy is this glass all alien.
That guy is just that's word salad.
That guy's high as fuck.
He just ramblin high as fuck.
I said the same thing in Joshua Tree one
time and this is the stuff by the way
that they kept in you know.
I mean think about that like especially
in the New Testament the New Testament.
They they had to like have like
meetings inside Ed what's in there.
Yeah.
Leave this if you look at two crazy if
you look at that is it go for twelve
quote.
Now it's totally changed has nothing
to do like really lately different.
Oh they've altered the quote Well you
know it also it's probably so hard.
You should talk to a linguist right.
You know I talked to a language scholar
the other day ironically enough for a
Bigfoot show.
And if you talked to a linguist they'll
tell you that it started off it was a
spoken story for the longest time
before anyone even wrote it down.
And the the bible must many of the stories
in the Bible probably existed before
language or before written language.
So like like a lot of the stories in the
Bible also they're like really similar
to the same stories of
ancient Mesopotamia.
Oh yeah.
Like somewhere and like the epic of
Gilgamesh is like really close to the epic
of Noah Noah's Ark.
It's like it's really like
a lot of similarities.
Yeah in a lot of the stories.
So they had to write it down the road
down and probably let's say the first ship
was the Sumerians so they wrote it down
and I think it's called cuneiform or
cuneiform.
They wrote it down then and
then eventually it became
ancient Hebrew and then
they're going to translate it ancient
Hebrew to Latin and then as translated to
Greek as translated to English like
they had to fuck it up in a lot of ways
along the way.
When you deal with some
wacky ass languages.
Q Matt I mean how many people even exist
and know how to convert all that shit.
Yeah I mean languages are lost.
Yeah.
And when they go over the the dead
sea scrolls is the real trip factory.
Read some of the shit that's in the dead
sea scrolls the dead sea scrolls of the
oldest version of the Bible by far by
almost a thousand years I think it was
found in a place called Kumbh Ron in these
these caves in the side of a mountain
like a side of a hill and these caves
have these clay pots and in them with
these they literally made out of animal
skins and it's the oldest stories of the
Bible and it's all trippy fucking shit
it's all you read it and you go it makes
Ezekiel sound normal right.
And it's so nutty that even though it's
the oldest version of the Bible they're
very resistant to release it.
And I like to say oh we're going to
revise the bible now according to the dead
sea scrolls.
They're like you know what.
We've been reading this for a while.
Maybe we need to fucking
just bury this bitch
because that's where that guy John Marco
Allegro who's the the dead sea scrolls
guy.
He was like the head translator
for the dead sea scrolls.
He said the whole thing
was about mushrooms.
He his he wrote a book called
The Sacred mushroom in the cross.
He was the only scholar on the whole
dead sea scrolls committee that was
agnostic.
He was ordained minister but then studying
theology realized it was horseshit
leaving booboo.
Yeah.
Say goodbye the people by guys.
We're gonna we're going to
wrap this up soon anyway.
We're gonna get out of here too.
I got to go see the premiere of serious.
Dr. Steven Greer documentary where he
reveals the truth about the tiny little
alien baby and whether or not
it came from the planet Uranus.
We please text me
immediately or live tweet.
Text me during it.
You know what.
What's going on.
I will text you but is
a show only for you.
I will save the rest of it
for when we talk on air.
So do not expect live tweets or spoilers.
I'm fascinated I actually talked to a
really cool guy today at a video game
company that saw it last night
and he said is really interesting.
So many get high as fuck and
we'll see what's up later buddy.
I see tomorrow man George S.
Myanmar.
Yeah.
So this dead sea scrolls.
This guy John Marco Allegro said after
like 14 years of study that the entire
Christian religion was really about
fertility rituals and mushrooms.
It was about tripping balls on psychedelic
mushrooms and it was about fertility
treatments and fertility festivals and
that they would fertility rituals and
that like becoming pregnant was like
the most important thing like keeping a
baby alive is really difficult
and becoming pregnant and
having you know a child
was like the most important
thing to look forward to.
Like there was a serious urgency to having
children because people were fragile
you know and they also knew a lot about
the indigenous psychedelic plants and
especially what they think the Amanita
miscarry mushroom he thinks was one of
the big ones that these people just didn't
want anybody else to know about it so
they hid their stories.
They hit him in parables and you know
they hid the how they know what their
history of the use of this stuff.
Really interesting stuff that I'm way
too stupid to understand whether he's
right or whether the
other people are right.
But the guy is a legit scholar you know
he's not a stoner he's not like one of
those guys is trying to
justify mushroom use.
There is something the Times that I've
tried mushrooms in which I know it sounds
stereotypical but I really
think there's something there.
I mean there's like definitely beyond
science and rationale and what I've been
told to expect in this and that there's
something there's something extra wild
about him and you know nothing's really
that great as when you can really enjoy
that.
Yeah and and it makes for everything I
mean luckily you know they're finally
coming out with these studies that are
showing what it's doing for depression
and anxiety and it's it's super natural
cure at times for people even with what
they called.
What are they come when
it's a lifelong diagnosis.
Chronic depression.
I mean people have bounced out of it
when they thought that they were going to
be miserable for the rest of their
lives it's like Oh thanks a real
consciousness reset on a real life a
real one not not not just like blowing on
your hand and pretending you feel
better it's it's real it's legit.
Listen to some of the shit that's
in the dead sea scrolls by the way.
There is people that are working really
hard to try to turn that around as of
the John Hopkins study and yeah my
friend Aubrey was just at maps the
psychedelic meaning whatever the hell
it is I forget what the what it was I
stand for maps.
Same map psychedelic I should know
because they're doing a lot of really good
work and letting people know it Intel
multidisciplinary Association for
Psychedelic Studies and you know they're
they're hitting them with hard science
over and over and over again and showing
how many people it can be beneficial
for which model and a lot of people that
are trying to hold back those people
that are trying to hold it back.
It would be beneficial to them as well
so people don't understand is that your
desire for your resistance to
psychedelics is the very reason you need
psychedelics in the first place.
If you really understood what you were
resisting like you're really holding God
back you really you really
want to believe in God.
Take 6 grams of mushrooms you'll see him.
Yeah you really party with them.
You'll hang out with them.
Dude DMV you'll have
you'll meet God for sure.
You say it sounds crazy it sounds like
an idiot saying it and I agree it's I.
It sounds like an idiot it's me.
I agree with you but I think it's probably
exactly what Zeke was talking about
in that story.
But he was tripping his balls off.
Oh yeah.
He had some crazy psychedelic experience
you probably ate some mushrooms or or
you know the Moses burning bush scholars
to this day actively in in Jerusalem
there.
There's a movement for
scholars to recognize the
possibility that Moses was on
psychedelic drugs.
And that's one of the reasons why it's
all a burning bush like one of the big
bushes that they that they associate
with that area as the acacia tree the
acacia Bush rich and DMC.
And if that doesn't mean that if they
figured out how to extract that shit and
smoke it burning bush is right there.
Yeah he met God.
He found out the 10 you know it sounds
like what God would say of your high end
EMT all those ten commandments
they sound pretty right.
Yeah.
Don't fuck your neighbor's wife.
Don't kill him.
Be nice.
Yeah it sounds like would be empty with
W like it literally is exactly what
D.N.A.
would tell you.
Translated to the filters of time
thousands of years of various languages.
But if some guy had some breakthrough
experience back then I was trying to
enlighten all the people around him.
That's what he would say.
I came back from God.
God gave me this message and then over X
amount of years of idiots talking about
it would not know.
Wrote it on stone tablets.
Well how did he know it was God's word.
Well God gave him.
Giants don't mean when people exaggerate
and tell stories of course good a
thousand years of people explaining what
happened they're going to fuck it up
and butcher it just makes sense.
What was the name of
that Mel Brooks movie.
It's one of my favorite scenes in comedy
history with Mel Brooks is playing
Moses and he comes around
the corner at three tablets.
My Lord I give you these 15 and he
drops the one these ten commandments.
Yeah.
So funny.
This is a this is a fucking fascinating.
These quotes I mean again I can't tell
you if these quotes are really from the
actual dead sea scrolls but it's
it's really wild crazy shit.
It's it's it's hard to understand how
you translate things to English because
it's not.
You're also trying to like display the
intent with a completely different style
of communicating.
You know like this style of communicating
that they had back then is probably so
alien to us like socially and so they
try to alter it to get it to fit and how
we feel they would communicate
if they lived today.
Yeah.
Many will attempt to steal your crown and
rob you of your joy but they can never
succeed because of my presence with you.
What you have hidden in the deep recesses
of your heart can never be removed by
the enemy of your soul.
Maintain a strong faith in me and my
word and you shall never perish but enjoy
life everlasting which
I have provided you.
That's sounds like a cult leader.
It sounds like a dude is trying to get
his dick sucked and he knows where all
the gold is
yeah life everlasting.
That's a hard promise to keep.
Who knows if that's what
it's really said though.
That's the really fascinating stuff
about all this really ancient shit.
It's like piecing together the past so
fucking hard to figure out when anybody
really said like this stuff that I've
been telling you about this Dan Carlin's
Hardcore History that I've been listening
to for the past couple of months.
They don't even know what gang is kind
of looked like they don't only look like
they don't know where they buried them.
They don't they they don't have
any direct quotes from him.
They have quotes from like people that
met with like Russian historians like
emissaries and you know diplomats that
met to like demand things before they you
know for the Mongols descended upon them.
Shit I read I read a thing about that
exactly that they hired like 50 people to
bury gang is gone and then they hired 100
people to kill those 50 people so that
nobody knew where he was buried and
then they hired 500 people to kill those
hundred people that killed the 50 people
in case any of them told them a thing
you know and they would just ambush these
groups of people that were under their
own command in order to protect
the secret of gang is gone.
They're bad motherfuckers.
They were willing to take it to a level
that human beings today could never
conceive of.
That's all I do now as I absorb all these
these this is history is unbelievable
to me.
And now with the Internet you can go
non stop tangent to tangent to tangent.
You can forget what
originally got you there.
Next thing you could just be on the
different scope of the universe.
But for some reason like tragic events
of twelve A.D. don't bother me as much as
like Boston of 2013.
Like I stopped reading
about the Boston tragedy.
Like I don't want to you know I'm hearing
about this guy lost his legs and this
people you know these people
were permanently injured
and this person died and
it's you know it's so depressing.
But for whatever reason I can read about
gangs can't or listen to this audiotape
bugging his car.
It doesn't bother me.
Yeah.
Sweet don't know how.
People are terrible they're capable
of such horrible horrible behavior.
We don't know.
We're not used to or
not around that often.
You have to see something
happen to just understand.
Oh yeah there's some of us out there
that are just fucking nuts right.
It's just in in in the
evolution of things.
It's hard to it's hard to get all the
way clear after a thousand years ago the
Mongol Lloyds were killing
tens of thousands of Mongol
Lloyd's great well with
long goals whatever
you can say whatever man they'll
come they'll come get you.
The thing is China's like their hero.
I mean imagine like that's that's
a guy that's in your your past.
You know we talk right.
What did what did your ancestors do.
Oh really.
My answer was getting his fuck my ancestor
killed everybody because King is Khan
fucked so many people that
he's responsible for a giant
percentage of the DNA in
that area like he's in something like 5
percent his DNA is in some I just made
that number up.
By
the way I'm going to google it okay
because it's not another fucking important
one of my historian.
Go look for yourself you.
If you want to find out get get that
Dan Carlin's Hardcore History I can't
recommend it enough the guy
puts a tremendous amount
of work in these podcasts I
really respect his work ethic I'm not
I'm fuckin fascinated by man Genghis Khan
motherfucker dude I'm saying Tony
Hinchcliffe Oh yeah definitely.
So well what's next for you buddy.
Except besides Wednesday
night at the ice house.
Can't wait for Wednesday Burt Chrysler
and Tommy Segura and Bryan red band.
Jesus Luisa's I love it.
I'm very excited.
We're gonna have some fun.
Mm hmm mm hmm.
What else is going on for you.
Still working on Jeff Ross's show.
Yeah we're in between seasons right now.
Hopefully Season 3 will be really soon.
The burn on Comedy Central and
you're one of the writers over there.
Yeah.
So if you see something really offensive
most likely that guy wrote it you know
who did it Tony Hinchcliffe.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Even if I didn't write for it I
fought for it to be on the show.
He's born gangster.
Look at that look at him.
It's true I not give a fuck.
Came out here from Ohio to
make it in the dark world.
It's true.
What you from Columbus originally from
Youngstown and a town in Italian city
between Chicago and New York.
I know where that is.
I did comedy there.
I did comedy in this club.
The funny farm.
Yeah.
And they had theirs there's the stages
in the bag and there's a disco in the
front and the disco was like
well it wasn't the highest end.
This guy you know not a holiday.
Yeah yeah.
Yeah.
And there was like all this music was
playing every time the back door would
open.
You would hear
it
and then it would close and
then you'd go back to your act.
It
would be like literally this quiet.
And the door would open.
So it's just constant
open and shut into pee.
You had to go that way I think yeah
I might have made that up to now.
No it wasn't a good gig.
That club was notoriously like.
Not really.
Did you ever do it.
No.
Never.
Some areas started out here.
So do you wanna go back to
just let everybody know I
went back a couple of times
when I first started and did pretty
big shows at a different bar.
But I was at a bar.
Oh you just did like
you got your own thing.
Yeah.
Looking you fuckin stud.
Would you do with you bring somebody.
It was just me actually
just you by yourself.
Yeah I have.
You're a savage.
Yeah I have a big a good great
group of friends back in Youngstown.
How much time do you have altogether.
Well altogether it's weird because no
matter what I'm trying to do I always go
off on tangents and whatever so that's
always I have to end up doing less than
my goal anyway.
And you makes a good problem to have.
Yeah yeah it is that you get that
problem we do a lot of comedy.
Yeah I do a lot of comedy on stage yeah.
How many days a week are
you going up every night.
That's how you do it.
Some nights like last week I had a couple
nights where it was three shows in one
night flying around just doing it.
Isn't it amazing when you do that because
coming home comes party DNA you know
really gets in that groove.
It's hard to do.
Trying to do.
Oh yeah.
I find I balance.
I like to do that.
I never liked you every night.
I like to do like three
or four nights a week.
Then I like to take nights a week off
and not even think about comedy and just
write where I don't I don't even I
don't even entertain the idea of going
onstage.
I just go over ideas you know and I find
that there's like for me I can't just
always be going onstage.
It's like a lot of time has to be spent
especially now working on I don't know
like my sixth or seventh hour or something
like that and all the time I put out
specials and shit.
It's like I have to I have to figure out
like new angles and new points of view
and not even this whole new point of view.
But new subjects new new different things
that interests me new points that I
have.
I feel like I don't I don't just
get that I I just go on stage a lot.
I have to spend a lot of time doing other
shit you know and I think about that
actively now whereas when I was younger
than I really think about that actively
like I would just try to like right you
know I just try to come up with new bits
but now I make myself do things.
So the cool stuff will come out of
my interesting stuff to talk about.
It was very soon after I started standup
once and the first couple weeks I found
a book that Stephen King wrote called
on writing yeah great book unbelievable
because it's a it's obviously you know
it's not a fiction he's just talking
about his work ethic of writing and he's
like I don't think I'm a writer if I
take a day off what am I
that I'm just some guy.
And so I started applying that during
the day and I figured you know on top of
writing my own standup if I keep up this
habit of writing for a few hours every
day during the day
then then it will get better.
And it did.
Sure enough you know luckily I'm
a member of the Writers Guild now.
Yeah.
Working on the show and everything.
So the habit was really it was that
book that gave me the confidence because
you're listening to Stephen King.
I mean yeah.
One of the best at what he does.
So one of the best of all time.
Yeah yeah.
I mean I'm a huge fan of that guy and I
just I can't have a thing about people
that produce stuff.
Yeah I find that like for me one of
the most inspirational things is to be
around a lot of other inspirational
people you know like when I like when I go
to a UFC I want to work out and after
I come home I want to fucking work out
like crazy when I go see comedy.
I want to write and I think
that's what's really important.
Oh totally.
I do that all the time even
with the music that I listen to.
Going somewhere getting ready
for something you know at night.
I listen a big powerful music that'll get
me you know sort of hyped and inspired
a lot of live shows is that type of
music that I listen to and you hear the
crowd just yeah.
Yeah.
In these breaks or at the beginnings or
at the end of the song and that's the
stuff that takes every little bit of
Mojo one can absorb to be able to kick it
back out.
Yeah that's why I really
like music as well.
I think music is one of the cool things
to see because it's like the energy is
putting it but it's totally
different from comedy.
It's like some new facet of
some new energy some new thing.
And like when I listen to a song like
some songs or suck something about it like
like there's a lyrical quality to like
writing in songs that I started to
realize somewhere along the line
is applicable to comedy as well.
Like when a good joke is written
correctly and a joke has a good economy of
words and the right words to describe
the right situations it has like a
rhythmic quality to it.
And I think that's sort of that's sort
of underestimated or overlooked by a lot
of comedians.
The impact that that sort of rhythm to
the delivery has the impact of it I think
is pretty substantial.
Oh totally.
But we don't think about that we just
think about what is funny but it's not
just that it's like it's funny and it's
also good and it's smooth and it's a lot
of things to it to make it more
enjoyable more interesting to listen to.
A perfect example of what you're talking
about right now with the rhythm and
like timing and everything.
Last night I'm hosting at the Comedy
Store it's like 40 comedians everybody
that's new and employees after that and
then paid regular whatever and in the
middle of it a cook that the Mexican
guy Aldo don't show who works the deep
fryer at the Comedy Store.
Hey man I want to go on stage
and barely speaks English at all.
I mean the impression I just did is making
him sound much more American than he
is.
And he he wants to do comedy
and I go you know what man.
All right.
But it's just gonna be two minutes okay.
This way in case it's you
know do whatever is right.
But you know and he goes up.
But it was hilarious because nobody
could understand a single word but he was
completely committed and then all of a
sudden he's making this noise and you
really you don't you don't know even
know what the noise he was making was but
his commitment and his beats with it
just he crushed he crushed and all these
other comedians that do it every night
and look at going up in that room at the
Comedy Store is like this is it.
I'm going to show them what I would
do on The Tonight Show if I was on it
tonight.
Then you have the guy work in the frying
pans who nobody understands a word.
There's people that spend so much time
writing and everything but there he is.
And it sure it's a silly instance
but it was extremely funny.
If I'm cracking up and the audience is
laughing and people are then it's funny.
And but you know it's really
and he did it without a word.
How do you how do you recreate that
could you recreate that with another
audience.
Maybe not.
And make maybe that would only work in
that sort of a really lose situation
where it's a comedy store.
Bunch comedians in the crowd right.
You want to go up you go up
and like no expectations right.
You know I mean it's like Could you
recreate that and become a comedian.
Right.
It was yeah because you know how that
that's a weird realization you have where
just because a joke kills in one place
it could bomb another place of total and
you say it the exact same way.
Yeah well what the fuck yeah.
And then you realize well well there isn't
like this isn't always work like this
this weird idea I'm throwing out there
yeah some people are gonna buy into it
and some people are not.
And sometimes it sounds like
the greatest joke ever written.
Sometimes it sounds like you're a fool.
Yeah because sometimes there's something
that happened the first time you did it
when it worked that you did before that
you don't normally do that you forgot
that you did and it
worked because of that.
And I think a good thing for young
comics to realize is that that's good.
It's good.
All those bombing and failing
and not getting it right.
It's good.
Oh yeah totally.
Because if you don't have it you're not
going to appreciate when it goes well.
I remember in my first few weeks of doing
it somebody went to a comedian came up
to me who I won't say his
name but he was terrible.
And he goes Hey man you know the
trick is bomb as often as you can.
I'm thinking myself Oh yeah that's what
you would do you'll lose there if that's
what you're doing anyway.
But mostly I got Americans to bomb.
What was his rationale.
Well he goes you know because now's
the time to knock bombing out.
Oh you know how to bomb now.
It ended up making some
sense Labor's terrible.
So how did you have such wisdom.
Right exactly.
Somebody must have.
Somebody must have told him that like
hey you know look at it this way in a
positive sense you're bombings.
Good.
I don't think back means
funny anymore makes me sad.
It's funny to you right now.
So close yeah.
Now just madness.
I look at it I just see madness this
people that you know that are going to try
for years and years and years and know
it's never gonna happen right doesn't
exist for them.
Yeah
it is creepy and I've seen it with
a few people but you with anything.
I mean you watch American Idol and people
saying and you like how is this person
think they've been saying they're crazy.
How does this person think anything what
anybody wants it must be that for if
you're a literary agent.
I mean imagine how many people send you
secret stories like Holy fuck are you
reading this nuts fucking work.
Read this.
What what is that.
Tony why why are some people
so goddamn delusional.
Is there a broad spectrum of human beings
and the amount of voltage your battery
puts out and some people are
just designed to dig holes.
I think that the delusion is you know the
delusion needs to be that with tons of
work at something you can accomplish it.
Not that the delusion is I can do this.
It's you've got to everybody that has
ever been good at anything worked at it
you know and I mean a lot.
So it's not and they wanted it.
And even if you work out it
doesn't mean you gonna get it.
Especially with things like talent
things like talent is a weird thing.
Like these guys I've seen guys that
like they train striking like for MDMA.
They train it for years.
They fucking trained for years.
But then when it comes and actually
fight they can't pull it off.
They just they can't
strike with people again.
They don't move right.
They're too slow for whatever reason
it is they can never figure it out.
And there's other guys who
show em a couple of moves
they lose like fucking pros
like instantly and they crush you
and knock you out with one punch.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's like either.
I mean it's like that guy
clearly has a gift right.
This guy clearly no matter how hard he
works he's never going to get there.
It's true.
The weird thing about this life boy must
be a real curse led to a crazy feeling
to be one of those guys.
It's like trying to pursue something
and you having no success and you can't
connect the dots and
you can't move forward.
Man it's you know before anything was
happening you know before when I was still
not making money and before I was getting
past at the clubs and Hollywood and
everything it was extremely low.
You know I was able to keep having
fun by surrounding myself around funny
friends and everything
but man was it hard.
Yeah it's depressing Yeah pressing as
fuck when you're not making it deck out
there.
It's hard but isn't it like
a real character builder.
Once you're through to the other side.
Like oh yeah he must
be so happy right now.
Oh yeah.
Yeah you're always smiling and shit.
I'll totally you're like
a professional comedian.
Boom got through.
It's wild.
You made it.
Yeah dude you you know you
fucking killed in Indianapolis.
There's a lot of goddamn people's 2000
people out there and you had to go up
cold and we knew who the fuck you were.
I love it.
Kill.
That's right.
That's the way I like it.
Yeah.
The audience loved you.
I love love.
A lot of positive tweets.
Man I thought you're funny.
Yeah it was a blast.
I listened to the set the next day
and I just couldn't even believe it.
This was really wild.
So we caught all those in the sound
and the power of that one was that the
biggest crowd you ever worked.
I think so right or right around there.
I should know but it's it's been right
around there with a couple of shows the
quote that was sorry about
this guy Phil Elmore.
He's a writer.
He wrote this on his Twitter.
So as a writer never has a vacation for
a writer life consists of either writing
or thinking about writing.
And that's Eugene you know sick go.
He was a playwright.
That's so true.
Psycho.
I can't sleep at night if I
didn't do something that day.
It's not a vacation.
I'm.
I work my vacation.
I think this is a blast.
I would be uncomfortable
for me is literally being
on an island for a week with
no internet and no.
Yeah.
Pen and paper.
Well people that don't stand
that like you need to relax Tony.
You need to stop working so hard they
understand that you're the only person
that can make Tony
Hinchcliffe jokes right.
If somebody likes you you're the
only person that that makes you.
You're the only person that performs
in your view you know that's it.
That's the only Tony Tony him Thomas.
Tony Hinchcliffe show around no one else
can do it unless they're in Vegas years
from now doing an impersonator act.
Right.
Right history is the autobiography of a
madman Alexander Herman son of bad ass
quote.
I read today might be
good wit in this show.
Tony Hinchcliffe thank you
for being a bad mother fucker.
Thank you so much for coming along and
and being one of those guys that I to
enjoy.
Enjoy your comedy man.
Happy to be part of it.
Happy to have you.
Welcome.
That's quite a bitch.
All right.
Thanks everybody for tuning
into the podcast tomorrow.
We'll be back with the
greatest welterweight champion
in the history of mixed
martial arts.
George NPR my friend joins us.
People say what you do to George Sapir
impression in front of him only with
George's blessing.
What the fuck that means Tony.
Help me out here the slack
pick up the slack Tony.
You mean George St.
Peter is gonna be sitting in this chair.
Yeah.
Don't rub your dick on it.
Son of a bitch.
Thanks a square space dot com.
Go to square space dot com
forward slash Joe and sign up.
Use the offer code Joe for and save 10
percent off your first purchase on new
accounts 30 bucks.
Thanks to Audible dot com go to Audible
dot com forward slash Joe and you'll get
one free audio book and 33
days of audible service.
Thanks also to taking candid talk.
What is it Rogan dot dot
com or something like that.
UPDATE ON A SECOND THING.
YEAH.
Rogan ducting dot com.
Go there your fox and save 25 bucks.
Think.
Yeah.
Twenty five bucks off of either a
phone or service and they're an awesome
company and they're very nice to us and
then know my mom we make really shitty
commercials like this.
Thanks to everybody else thanks to on it
use the code name Rogan save 10 percent
of O and I tee off any other supplements
and that's it ladies and gentlemen I
apologize for my brain being mush lately
I've been working a lot on this other
show as well as doing this and I
feel it I feel it Tony I feel stupid.
Help me out buddy.
May 3rd 4th and 5th.
San Francisco Sacramento.
The Death Squad says Tony
Hinchcliffe in the House pitches.
That's it.
All right folks.
We will see you tomorrow.
We love the shit out of you.
And Godspeed.
Not because.